yeah
hello everyone and welcome to this the
um budget meeting of um mid-suffolk
District councilor I'm councilor James
Caston chair of the council
um before this meeting commences I'd
just like to ask everyone to stand if
they can
in um solidarity to the Ukraine because
tomorrow is a year since the Russian
invasion so if I if people would like to
just stand for a minute
solidarity thank you
um May I first remind you so may I first
remind you of some domestic Arrangements
the toilets are situated outside the
meeting room opposite the stairs cold
water is also available in the breakout
area outside the meeting room if the
fire alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones and
turn laptops to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of this meeting will be filmed
except where they're confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed by entering
the meeting you are also Convent
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
Press May record film photograph and
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
and they'll move to the agenda
item one is apologies for absence
thank you chair I have received
apologies for absence from councilor
Guthrie and counselor eburn
thank you very much Declarations of
Interest by councilors so in accordance
with delegated authority the monitoring
officer has granted dispensations to all
members in respect to the 2324 budget
papers are there any other Declarations
of Interest count counselor Manson
uh thank you chair um I I'd like to just
declare that I am the event director for
the park Crown which goes on at Chilton
Fields uh which is related to uh the
Shelf project uh I had a conversation
with um John Robinson um who says that I
am able to uh participate
thank you very much
councilor Pratt was that a um
declaration yeah I'd just like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest as a
school teacher at Stone Market High
School okay thank you very much
any others
councilor Carter
declaring Aid non-cuny interest as a one
of my daughter goes to Woodley which is
the part of the Shelf project
s okay thank you very much is that
all of them thank you
so
um we'll now move on to item three which
is mc2233 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 26th of January 2023
for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
Council Stringer yeah thank you I was at
that meeting as many of us were I don't
believe it started at 5 30 P.M
okay thank you we'll take that on board
um
thank you Mr chairman on page
sub sentence it says uh only mandatory
if they effect I believe it should be
perfect
okay thank you very much
so um with with those um changes
um could I have a proposal for the
minutes please
councilor hadnam and a seconder
councilor epignon
oh could we'll take this by hands and
could all in favor please please put
their hands up
say that's pretty much unanimous that's
unanimous
thank you so it's carried
so um item four is um Chairman's
announcements I refer you to the paper
mc2234 for noting thank you very much
and um thank you everyone that's um
bought a ticket for my um dinner night
in the officer's mess on the 4th of
March and um I hope you enjoy yourself
and we raise plenty of money for the
charity
so um
thank you item five leaders
announcements
I'd like to invite councilor Morley to
present her update
thank you chair
tomorrow
Friday the 24th of February marks the
one-year anniversary of Russia's illegal
invasion of Ukraine
since the War Began thousands of
ukrainians have been killed defending
their freedom from Russia's appalling in
onslaught
Millions more have been forced from
their homes with many finding refuge in
the UK under the homes for Ukraine
scheme including nearly 350 here in
mid-suffolk
tomorrow at 11 o'clock there will be a
national moment of silence
offering people the chance to pay a
tribute to the courage of the Ukrainian
people and to demonstrate the UK's
unwavering solidarity with the country
I'm sure I speak for all of us at
mid-suffolk District Council when I say
we continue to stand with Ukraine
I'm pleased to say suffolk's district
and Borough councils including
mid-suffolk have secured 2.2 million
pounds worth of government funding
to improve the standard of private
rental homes in the county this will
tackle poor housing conditions and
improve tenants well-being
the funding from dlac will be used to
create and support additional roles
offering advice to tenants and landlords
and take enforcement action against
those who let poor quality housing
it will also enable the councils to
continue working collaboratively calling
resources to improve the standards of
privately rented homes
suffolk's public sector leaders group
agreed last week to fund a plan which
aims to end Russ sleeping in our County
by 2027.
during the pandemic 160 people sleeping
on the streets were accommodated in
Suffolk in six weeks including 42 in
just one day under the everyone in
initiative
we have wanted to build on that work in
Suffolk and provide a sustainable
solution to the problem and help more
people through a preventative approach
175 000 pounds has been agreed to
develop the program to develop the plans
which include more support for young
people leaving local Authority care who
are at greater risk of homelessness
in another great
collaborative approach we take in
Suffolk public sector leaders also
agreed to fund a new supported Food
Network
it will work with new and existing food
Outlets including food banks providing
more stock and ensuring a range of
enhanced support is available to meet
local needs
it will also focus on early help and
prevention upskilling and additional
support around benefits
spsl agreed 1.5 million pounds funding
over three years for this project led by
the collaborative communities board and
I'm sure this will build on the
outstanding work of food banks Community
ladders and other Charities helping more
people in the cost of living crisis
sbsl had previously placed 1.8 million
pounds to the local welfare assistance
scheme which saw more than 7 000
applications for help between October
and December last year
spsl has also published a report
highlighting some of our key
achievements in the last two two years
sorry in the last two-year term
and these include committing 1.3 million
to tackle gangs county lines and
trafficking pledging more than 2 million
championing Suffolk as a place to do
business and supporting Town centers
and investing 756 000 pounds on work to
improve the Energy Efficiency of
Southern Homes and 1.5 million to
support suffolk's ambition to be Net
Zero by 2030.
I'm delighted to say our Council has
been shortlisted for five national
awards
our Gateway 14 project which will bring
thousands of jobs to the area is a
well-deserving finalist in the asset
management and regeneration category in
the IES public sector transformation
awards for 2023
our tree canopy survey and tree planting
strategy has been shortlisted in the
local government Chronicle Awards in the
technology category and the ieasy awards
in the green Public Service category
we've also been shortlisted for the
national 2023 smarter working live
Awards which celebrate public sector
excellence
for our commitment to staff well-being
the council has been recognized in the
putting people first category
and our local land charges department
has been shortlisted in the 2023 land
data local land charges award
it is fantastic to see our Council being
recognized like this and I'd like to
congratulate everyone involved for all
of these achievements
I've mentioned a couple of points
about how we work with Suffolk public
sector leaders but I think it's worth
just running through a few extra extra
points
so last Friday we held the last spsl
public meeting before the elections in
May so I think this is an opportune
moment to update you on what we have
been doing
so we've agreed important financial
support for the collaborative
communities board
and the housing board and I'm just going
to
whiz down a few statistics
2.35 million to support business and the
County's post covered recovery program
of which 1.4 million has been put into
the Suffolk inclusive growth investment
fund which has supported several
projects
including virtual High Street innovate
local and Innovation labs
1.35 million to tackle county lines and
criminal exploitation
1.5 million to deliver the Suffolk
climate emergency plan
756 000 to improve the Energy Efficiency
of homes
an additional 80 000 for screen Suffolk
following the setup support in 2016.
half a million for the county council's
get Suffolk reading initiative
half a million for the collaborative
communities board and 400 000 for
Suffolk Family Focus for preventative
work to support vulnerable people
two hundred thousand for the integrated
care Academy to support young people and
their Mental Health
and one of them for the local welfare
assistance scheme to support residents
facing financial hardship
also one million earmarked with Hawley
Junction one million earmarked for the
housing board and 375 000 earmarked for
the Wars project
so that's just a few of the things that
we've been getting up to over the last
couple of years
there is a end of term report that's
available on the County Council website
and I'll include a link to that in my
thank you very much councilor Morley are
there any questions for clarification
no okay Sir William we'll move on to
item six
to receive notifications of petitions in
accordance with the councilor procedure
rules
thank you chair and unreceived item
seven questions by the public in
accordance with the council procedure
rules none received item eight questions
by counselors in accordance with the
council procedure rules none received
keep me
so we'll um move on to item nine which
is
mc2235 which is general fund budget
2023-24 and the four-year Outlook
I refer you now to the amendment in the
table papers received from the green and
liberal Democrat group
as the budget reports
are complex items I am minded to allow
the proposer of the report
um the story of the amendment 10 minutes
to introduce their item please note that
the deadline for submitting amendments
to the budget papers has passed and
there can be no further amendments
submitted this evening
but first I would like to invite
councilor Whitehead
to introduce paper
mc2235 and to move the recommendations
in the report
councilor Whitehead
thank you chairman
um I'm pleased to have the opportunity
to introduce the general fund budget 23
24 and four year outlook
so when the annual budget comes before
full Council it's already been to
Cabinet briefings to various political
group briefings to an all member
briefing twice it's come before I review
scrutiny the penultimate stage comes
before cabinet for endorsement full
Council
so with this in mind I will dwell just
on a few key points while being happy to
be happy to answer any members questions
before we move on to debate the budget
so as we approach the end of this
current Administration the 2324 budget
and four-year Outlook covers a whole
period about a month and a few days of
the next Administration
therefore seems logical to me to say
that this forward-looking report
sets out this cabinet's financial Legacy
to the next Administration
a crucial set of data that I consider to
be vital when we're considering and
appraising the 23-24 budget
is a forecast in the four-year Outlook
our medium-term projections
because any decision we make for 23 24
must be based on long-term
sustainability of the council's finances
so any proposal to freeze our council
tax precept must only be evaluated and
taken in the context of our medium-term
projections
and we can see these projections set out
in table eight and all the various
assumptions built into projections are
set out in paragraphs 4.41 to 4.49
and over that four year period we are
forecasting a cumulative surplus of 8
million
and these projections assume no
replacement for new homes bonus before
Beyond 24-25
despite new homes bonus being crucial
income for most other Borough councils
and District councils so there will
surely be something to all councils from
government to take its place
the projections also assumed no further
growth in business rates despite
significant growth that will inevitably
come from the Gateway 14 as well as
elsewhere within the district
rejections also assume no further
increase in fees and charges Beyond this
current year
so with the council tax of 23 and 24
quite possible beyond based on these
projections we can objectively
demonstrate that our medium-term
finances are abundantly secure and
robust
this is our administration's Financial
Legacy
we're currently in inflationary times
but hopefully we're now moving beyond
its high watering short-term Peaks and
the latest forecast from City Group this
year this week is that inflation should
get back
to be 22 Target levels or below early in
the Bank of England forecast
looking back over the seven year time
frame that I've held this cabinet post
and presented seven budgets to full
Council
retail price is not period have risen by
nearly 35 percent
our midst of a precept in contrast is
risen by less than eight percent
I inherited a Bandy precept of 159 pound
37 and seven years later it's 171 power
59 it's increased by less than eight
percent over a full seven years
had it increased by retail price
inflation it would be over 215 pounds
so midsummit conservatives have been
doing our bit for our residence cost of
living since 2016.
I must also mention our Reserve position
and some proposed changes to them going
forward
when the council commenced the
development to Gateway 14 it did so by
lending money to Gateway 14 limited the
holy ounce subsidiary set up to deliver
this ambitious project
the sale of a large tract of land to the
range in December 22 has now just
de-risked the project
the interest accrue on the loan has now
all been paid and so the large
commercial development risk management
Reserve that we established can now be
repurposed
we're proposing the person to come by
that with our growth and efficiency
reserve and part of the anticipated 20
to 23 Surplus into one
it's like having cuckoo clock into one
um
into one large
new strategic transformation in
infrastructure fund
that fund should grow to be in excess of
9 million in the new Financial year
the Legacy we wish to fund future
investment in transformation and
infrastructure
we're also going to set up a new
Community Development Fund reserve of
half a million pound to support local
communities and organizations with the
delivery of local place-based
initiatives and activities
well full extent of our reserves is set
out on table five under paragraph 440.
finally our Capital program forms a
vital part of our ongoing investment in
the future for our Council
and to our anticipated carry forward
from 2223 of 19.229 million we are
proposing quite a further 7.188 million
in 2324 and all the details of this plus
the three-year Capital projections so
set out by project and by service area
in appendix a
well as I said earlier man I'm happy to
answer any questions on report presented
today
but I may recall on members of the
finance team here to help with any
questions on any granular detail
I'd like to pay tribute to our finance
team this is Melissa's first budget as
the section 151 officer and I applaud
the way she has transitioned into that
senior role
she's been able assisted by Rebecca
Hewitt who sadly is leaving us shortly
I also want to publicly acknowledge the
hard draft of Sharon Bayless who's
generously loaned back into Finance to
do a sterling job in the budget
preparation process that's just three
names from within a larger and much
appreciated Finance team but I say thank
you to all involved
so Mr chairman I'd like to move the
recommendation of 3.1 and 3.2 in the
report
that the general fund budget proposal to
23 24 and the four-year Outlook be
approved and that next year's general
fund budget is based on no increase to
the present Bandy council tax of 171
power 59 and that of course is abandoned
from which all other domestic dwellings
from band a to band H are calculated
Mr chairman I commend this budget to
full Council thank you
thank you very much and we we had a bit
of a disturbance during that which would
normally end in a fine but because the
counselor in question made a very
generous donation to my charity just
before this meeting I I I won't find her
or neighbor at this point so um we'll
move on but everyone be warned
could I have a um secondary please
councilor Morley right so now um oh
sorry councilor morning
yeah I'm happy I'm happy to second that
Council I think
so um now we'll um deal with this
amendment
that's come in so I'd like to invite
councilor Mellon to propose to the
amendment for the green and liberal
Democrat group
um thank you Mr chairman members um in
proposing this amendment let me first
take you back to happier days three
years ago
early 2020 many of us still felt like
new councilors we were still finding our
way and this is before the pandemic
kobit 19 was still something far away in
Wuhan rather than the massive threat it
became
and whilst Ukraine was at war with
separatists in the East they had not
been yet fully invaded by Russia
and of course Theresa Mavis prime
minister so these were simpler times
happier times for some
but not for everyone for many people in
this Suffolk they were already struggles
with the cost of living and heating
their homes according to figures from
the Department of Business energy and
Industrial strategy
in 2017 there were 43 000 odd homes in
fuel poverty
and out of the districts and boroughs in
Suffolk our district mid-suffolk had the
highest proportion of these 10.2 percent
of households
and the situation here why not here but
mid-suffer over there is exacerbated by
the fact that 53 over half the homes in
the district are not connected to the
gas grid and so are depends on other
often more expensive ways to keep warm
now fast forward to now and as we all
know the global situation has changed
radically we've had the pandemic and
we're still recovering from that
we've had Putin's appalling illegal
invasion of Ukraine and all the
horrendous consequences that are
followed from it
whose rise is in the price of food and
fuel and the cataclysmic effects on many
household finances
and we've also had brexit and whether
you were for or against that decision is
had some effect
and we've had a certain amount of
political turmoil here in the UK which I
won't go into since I don't want to
bring back painful memories from my
colleague's opposite
also perhaps dwarfing all these other
immediate issues we have the looming
problem of climate change and even at
this early stage we're seeing alarming
effects record temperatures around the
world including here in Suffolk droughts
and wildfires and the emergence of a
disturbingly unstable climate just as
our scientists have predicted
and it's perhaps inevitable those
figures for fuel poverty have got worse
in the last couple of years because of
the factors I've mentioned
the most recent figures show that 28 of
households in Suffolk that's around 95
000 homes are now in fuel poverty
and whilst the government has provided
generous Support over the last few
months that support is coming to an end
and off gem are also likely to increase
the price cap for energy again at the
end of March
now amazingly there are measures we can
take which can help with all these
different things they can help with the
energy crisis
cost of living crisis and also address
our climate Ambitions I'm talking of
course about energy saving measures home
insulation energy conservation reducing
the amount of of energy that a home
requires through efficiencies
this means lower cost it means warmer
homes and it means lower emissions there
are multiple benefits
is why I'm putting forward our Amendment
to the budget today
we are proposing that the council puts
aside two million pounds representing
about 10 percent of our reserves in
order to tackle the cost of living
crisis the energy crisis and the climate
crisis
with our excellent officers looking for
ways to deliver it targeted at the most
in need then families across the
district could be enjoying the benefits
as soon as next winter
now it would be wrong for me to stand
here this evening and say that there is
nothing currently happening in this area
of work because clearly there is we have
the warm home Suffolk program doing
exactly this sort of thing but currently
on a limited scale we also have the
Legacy programs the warmer homes healthy
people initiative still providing
providing advice and help and the spsl
has recently agreed to fund the fuel
poverty retrofit team which will provide
staff to support all this work
so we are not proposing a wholly new
program which needs to be designed it
could well be that the funding we set
aside today could be used to support and
expand these existing programs
current funding has been a little bit
hit and miss as with so much of
government funding we have to beat
competitively when funding pots become
available and so whilst councils in
Suffolk have been successful is not the
comprehensive long-term funding that
this area of work desperately needs
so to summarize we propose that 2
million is set aside from reserves to
tackle these interconnected crisis
crises
is this proposal affordable yes it is we
have over 22 million in reserve so this
is less than 10 of that total is it
legal yes we have the section 151
officer's agreement that this will not
unbalance the budget
is it needed
I mentioned earlier that the latest
figures show the number of households in
Suffolk in fuel poverty the warm homes
program currently targets around 250
homes per year but aims to rise to 500
750 and eventually a 1500 homes per year
even at that rate it would still take 60
years 62 years to retrofit all of those
homes in fuel poverty so there's plenty
of room plenty of scope to expand what
is already being done
lastly is this amendment appropriate
to me the last year has seen the coming
together of various factors to give the
modern world a severe shock
and people are suffering the
consequences of that shock
this council is sitting on resources
that can make a difference not just
bailing people out for now but making a
long-term difference
and we know that 2 million will not
retrofit all of mid-suffolk but targeted
at those most in need it would help so I
encourage you to support this amendment
I was looking forward to councilor e
Burns
seconding it seconding it unfortunately
she's not able to be here but I
understand there's going to be a second
death from the administration uh Rachel
if you're listening I wish you well I
hope you soon feel better thank you
thank you and I'd like to Echo those
words to You and councilor even
um so um can I have a second to please
second is this motion
um
I mean
two million pound isn't a trivial sum
you know it's not like trying to find a
needle in a haystack or one green MP in
a full Parliament but at the same time
but at the same time you know looking at
it in terms of total reserves
um two million pound is is relatively
it's relatively small some and I think
um the
councilman has put a good case forward
to take this as an addition to our to
our budget and on that basis I'm happy
to accept it
thank you very much um councilor
Whitehead so you've accepted the
amendment so I'll go to councilor Morley
the seconder
um do you accept the amendment
yes chair I do
thank you very much so we'll um now go
to um that now becomes a substantive
motion and we'll go to questions and
um I'll ask um
councilors to um speak as many times as
they like but please keep it to the
subject matter
um under discussion
um so um who would like to start with
questions councilor Passmore
thank you very much chairman one of the
points about any scheme like this is how
will you decide or who will decide who
is targeted and who isn't because one of
the potential challenges those that are
just over the line that get nothing I
just wondered if anybody who got any
thoughts or whether that needs to be
considered and we come back by our email
after it but I do think that's important
so how would it be targeted who would be
eligible and so on please
does anybody want to take that um
question or should we um
go into it later in email
um councilor Mathison do you want to
take the question
yeah or do you have a question
yeah so okay thank you yeah um I feel
that the um the question of Eligibility
is already been dealt with on under the
Walmer home scheme and so that should be
all right
so that's how it's going to be done is
it do we know
yeah so that will be a cabinet decision
so um that will be forthcoming uh I hope
um so um now we've got councilor Fleming
yes thank you and thank you very much
and um yeah I'm also I think in
principle happy to support this
amendment because I feel that um not to
support it actually would probably run
against some of the things we already
wish to do and um that are already in
our budget but I do have a question and
that is is there anything in this
amendment that would or could
upset the budget that was originally
proposed that could alter it
should we go to council Whitehead with
that or would you like to um yeah I mean
I mean I'm happy to take our section 151
officer's opinion on this but from my
point of view I've got no concerns
so um would you like to comment
just to agree as already said I've got
no concerns either I'm in support of
this
thank you
yeah so um yeah just to make things
clear we're um this is now the
substantive motion and we're we're
questioning the whole budget not just
the amendment so um it's now the now now
the
um budget does include that Amendment
and the questions will be on that but if
you want to ask questions on the
amendment you can
councilor scarf
well mine is specifically on the reserve
situation
um we're creating this new strategic
transformation and infrastructure fund
which actually I personally welcome
future Council projects but in doing so
we are transferring what's left of the
growth and efficiency fund Reserve as it
was
um I asked a question at scrutiny and I
was given the answer by councilor
Whitehead at school it was the full
intention that the authority continued
to fund the councilor's locality
allowance scheme now this was originally
funded from the growth and efficiency
fund and obviously if it's merged into a
new fund I welcome that confirmation
that it will continue and indeed I think
scrutiny actually recommended that there
was an increase which has yet to be
determined but I do think that rather
puts us at odds with the position in
statement form I must push you to a
question
the question is it puts us in in
contravention of 4.32 which says that
reserves only provide one-off funding
and I do have a problem with that
because I think it should be a line in
the budget says the county budget X
whatever we decide on so why is it not
in the budget because if we're not
supposed to use reserves for that
purpose then why is it not in the budget
as a line in the budget and that's the
account for the Whitehead
I'm not sure I can give you a specific
answer as to why it's not a line item
but I can assure you that the councilor
locality grants which are 7 350 pound
for each Council which is 249 900 in
total is is in there for next year we've
also rather than increasing that per
capita figure we've also put this 500
000 Community uh Development Fund aside
for local projects which is basically so
effectively from a locality's point of
view we've traveled the amount that's
there for next year
thank you any further questions Council
field
thank you chair uh just really that the
uh fairly basic one I guess but the the
the budget or the the preambled your
papers talks very much about uh the
second quarter uh outturns and we know
certainly in this Council we get some
dramatic changes usually in around
quarter four where we realize how
pessimistic we've been about
um income and uh and uh how we've
overestimated expenditure so really
question is since um quarter three is
now gone in fact it's it's six weeks ago
that I think we passed that Milestone I
was just uh asking for your reassurance
that there's nothing in here that has
changed significantly you know we
haven't finished up either
a vast over spend or shed loads of spare
cash as we often do really are those
figures that are based on quite ancient
history still accurate
thank you councilor Whitehead
I've only very preliminary chord three
numbers because at that stage they were
going to see the leadership team but
nothing I saw in there but you know it
scared me or anything and I think
there's no surprise main surprises
either positive or negative but again
perhaps I've been concentrated which on
the budget so again if a Melissa could
just perhaps elucidate this to what her
thoughts are on quarter three it might
be helpful thank you director corporate
resources
thank you chair
um yeah I'm happy to confirm that
actually is in line with Quarter Two
there's very little movement from
Quarter Two to quarter three so no
surprises at the moment I'm pleased to
say
councilor Stringer
thank you thank you chair uh a couple of
points then I'll ask a question
um
councilman I will intervene there and
I'll say that this is a question this is
a question and such a blatant disregard
for that I'd say blatant I would say uh
good news to Beyonce uh but anyway okay
I'll just ask the question uh in in your
introduction at Council Whitehead you
mentioned that business rate income will
rise when uh as Gateway 14 fills up the
businesses and stuff it's my
understanding that Gateway 14 is part of
a Freeport and doesn't pay business
rates so if that is the case where will
that business rate income come from
councilor White's head
yes although the business as hell's work
figures
Mount will come from central government
then it's a very complex
way that it's allocate into pops a b or
B1 and B2 and C or whatever
um but basically we're certainly with no
worse off as a council probably better
off with this report status and if we
were identical
identical businesses being on that site
as non-free port
thank you very much and I feel that oh
it counts the past more so wait just one
other thing just your clarification if I
may there's been some reports uh in the
media recently I think this week
regarding local authorities particularly
districts and boroughs and the provision
of leisure facilities
the question I was just going to ask and
I'm sure the answer is yes but
confirmation and I know we can't hold
future administrations
um
bindings and so on but there will be
sufficient robustness in the budget that
we have and reserves and so on to make
sure that our important Leisure
facilities at stradbroken Stone Market
will be maintained because they do
actually help with the fabric of uh
Mid-South I think it's very important so
just a quick answer will be plenty thank
you chairman
thank you council department councilor
Whitehead yes I am
thank you very much and that will be the
end of the questions thank you very much
we'll move on to um debate and councils
will be
um allowed to speak once for three
minutes and um this will be time so does
anybody want to start off debate
councilor flattman
can you hear me yeah lovely okay so um
we understand and appreciate the
challenges for our Leisure centers
providers stradbroke and laxfield at
this time especially the combination of
building back after curve 19 and the
unprecedented increase in utility costs
we have already supported them by
installing a series of solar related
Investments to reduce the costs of their
electricity requirements include a solar
pack including solar panels and the most
recent Investments of solar carports
with which are a pilot we will
understand how well they are working
after their first full year of operation
in the meantime we know our provider is
doing what they can to reduce their
consumption and limit the impact of the
increases and we are working closely
with them to identify what we can do to
support them and hope this is useful
along with everything else we're doing
with them so and I think I have a
meeting with them next week so um yeah
we keep them
keep up to date all the time okay thank
you
thank you councilor flatman
um I can't see any more hands for oh
councilman Matheson
a relatively um minor Point really but I
I would like to see that some of the two
million pounds that we've we've just put
into the budget is actually used for
training in particular retrofit
um work because at the moment the
um the building industry uh is shedding
is shedding labor and and already we we
see on our televisions and
um people who have not got work at the
moment now these are the very people
that would have the skills or could have
the skills and it's got the background
to to actually do the retrofit work so I
I would like to think that we would work
together with the
other councils in Suffolk and and the
relevant educational
education institutions to
um to actually really boost that that
aspect up
um because
it is a particular skill set and we are
going to need it um and we need to do it
a lot quicker than the 60 years that um
councilman suggested um were a
possibility unless we scale things up a
lot I think
thank you councilor Mathison and will
now have cancer councilor Stringer and
following him councilor Davies
thank you chair uh sorry took prolong
this I could have done it once uh
I'll be supporting this budget now
minted budget thank you and thank you
for accepting the amendment uh the
existing we've been deliberately
non-prescriptive in how this is done
because even the current Frameworks that
exist are not perfect uh there's a
number of people that wanted to be
involved in the current Frameworks and
because the Energy Efficiency uplift was
what what was not perfectly one scale
point they they didn't qualify but they
did qualify on a financial footage so we
couldn't help them the amount we could
help them because it wasn't one scale
point on the Improvement of the building
so I think we if we look at the current
framework to see where people are
falling through the net that would be a
really good use of some of this money
as well as other areas where we
desperately need to get our housing
stock
as in Mid-South at PLC it improved
I would also like to there was there was
a question I'd probably like to answer
it it was asked whether this would
create an upset in the uh existing
budget I'm simple sold I looked up what
upset means it means an unexpected
result or situation
if by unexpected result it means we
actually for once spend the budget that
we are allocating today I would welcome
such an upset thank you
thank you councilor Davies
sorry one thank you
I too will be supporting this motion
um
if I read the documents correctly when
it comes to our employees we're I think
proposing a two percent increase in
their salaries clearly it's not the
Forum to discuss the details but I just
like to hear the view that possibly we
might improve our retention of our staff
if we increased the lower paid ones more
thereby helping them in these difficult
times
so that was my thought for the day
yeah can I go to the chief executive
thank you
thank you counselor and I wouldn't
disagree with the principal you put
forward I just wanted to provide a bit
of clarity so what's being proposed
within the budget is four percent for
next year in relation to staff and then
two percent each year thereafter
um but as councilors will be aware that
some whatever that sum ends up being is
not actually within our gift anyway
there's something that's negotiated
nationally on our behalf as it happens
we have today uh seen the sums come in
in terms of what's being proposed by the
employers to put to the unions as
complicated I'm happy to share it
outside the meeting rather than trying
to go through it I literally was just
reading it as you asked the question
um but it comes in below that four
percent level so in terms of the budget
assumptions we would be within that
amount of money assuming that that's the
final agreed amount and of course it's
it's early days in any negotiation but
just wants to provide that Clarity in
terms of uh how that may play through
and what's proposed within the budget
foreign
thank you very much
um any further contributions for debate
Council field
thank you
I can read this after my uh recent uh
attention to my eyes
um I just wanted to say something about
the the amendment really
um
the issue was that if we're really
serious about helping the most
vulnerable in society about attacking
and fuel
poverty and about showing all the rest
of us what we need to need to do to meet
the challenges of climate change then we
need to up our game dramatically that
was Council of melons with his own we we
are indeed doing things now but not
nearly as much as is necessary
um
and we hit on this side of the chamber
certainly argued many times that we
should do that
um
I think it's quite clear that some
changes that we're talking about to to
lower bills to make healthier buildings
some of them are quite easy to do
you can add roof insulation to a house
for instance others are costly things
like swapping out triple double glazing
for triple glazing they're quite easy to
do but expensive some are valuable
and necessary but costly and quite
difficult things like cladding walls are
something that it's quite easy to all
get wrong I think there's a tower
somewhere in London that suffered that
sort of problem
and I think to get this underway people
need motivation to tackle the task help
and Guidance with the choices they may
need to make and many may need help with
the cost
but if we cannot kick this upgrade
process into action then still skilled
and daughters will become available and
costs will reduce
so uh for those reasons I personally
wholeheartedly support this amendment
and are obviously support budget itself
as well thank you
thank you councilor field councilor
Passmore
Third Time Lucky thank you chairman well
I'm very happy to support
um the amendment along with the uh the
original emotion I just want to point
out that I think it's very very
commendable there is a council tax
freeze that in itself will be very very
helpful to people I only wish in another
role I could have done the same there
um but it does make a difference to
people and I think what John was saying
about the level of council tax over the
last uh well few years
um is worthy of note and it does need to
be remembered but of course apart from
the amendment there are other things
that we mustn't forget sight of and that
is in my opinion only
um getting the economy going providing
more jobs higher value jobs and so on is
really really crucial so we can lift
people's aspirations particularly for
those just entering the workforce so
they are able to be I suppose more
economically independent so as I said
I'm certainly welcome the amendment it
does of course go alongside the work
that Susie spoke about in public sector
lead
there I think that will be very very
beneficial there have been and I know
some people argue not enough but there
have been some significant rises in the
state pension for next year and one or
two other benefits as I say It's never
enough but there are other things that
we should be doing and maybe I think
there's reference to this in the in the
budget paper when it comes to social
value and procurement and these sorts of
things we really really really do need
far better in the public sector to
support I would say here certainly
mid-suffolk and Suffolk PLC but
certainly UK PLC whilst we don't buy
lots of food and drink here in
mid-suffolk and nevertheless other
organizations across the public sector
do and if we are talking about carbon
footprint reduction so on and saving
food miles and so on we need to start
waking up a bit better and do something
about it we can all do that as
individuals we in our procurement should
be looking at things like social value
to make sure we maximize what we're
doing with taxpayers money to help keep
the wealth and generate more and here so
just didn't want to lose sight of those
things it's not just about the amendment
as I say I welcome it but the other
things that we need to be doing as well
and that was one of the reasons chairman
I asked about Leisure facilities and
thanks Julie for the reply for that
because that all makes the area more
attractive and that can reassure people
so there's a lot of very good positive
messages in this budget so I'm
wholeheartedly behind it and look
forward to perhaps having
now that would be a real thing to have
thank you
thank you very much councilor Richardson
thank you very much chair um I'm
actually going to say almost exactly
what cancer Passmore said but I'll try
not to repeat myself too much
um I I totally agree I think there's
there's two kind of main points
um here for me the first is around the
freezing of council tax to begin with
and I totally agree with what councilor
Whitehead said at the beginning in terms
of this being a very strong Legacy uh I
know that for us as a district council
our component of the precept is not the
largest and so we can get into arguments
or debates about how much of a
difference it will make if we put it up
or don't but actually looking back
reflectively those last seven years to
put it up only by eight percent across
that time period and seeing or hearing
um the difference in terms of what the
preset for the average band D might have
been I think is it is a really strong
point and I think it reflects incredibly
well on the finances of this Council and
how they've been managed over a number
of years but and I I take um obviously
happy that the Administration has
accepted the amendment because I think
that demonstrates the second point is
that not only have we managed to keep
council tax low over a seven year period
we've done so while still investing in
our communities while still trying to
grow the economy exactly as cancer
Passmore has said there are quite a few
exciting things coming down the track in
mid-suffolk the state Market health
education Leisure facility that's on the
agenda is one the skills Innovation
Center
another and I think on this last example
count straight from you you'll agree
with me that obviously one of the
largest transfers in this budget is to
mid-suffer growth limited which we'll be
continuing to deliver affordable and
high quality housing for our residents
all of which boosts our local economy so
I think that's a very strong Legacy I'm
delighted to see that there seems to be
a consensus growing in the chamber so I
shall certainly be in voting in favor of
this budget thank you chair
thank you councilor epignon
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm grateful to councilor Richardson
for talking about mid Suffolk growth
which has I think
um performed absolutely fantastically in
terms of its remit to build high quality
housing accommodation for our residents
it's one plank of a series of economic
measures that this council is a has been
able to pursue because of the way in
which we've successfully managed the
finances of this Council and
the other element of this is the fact
that we are in a position where uh with
our Gateway 14 project not only have we
achieved uh many of our initial
objectives uh in up to there but we are
actually looking at a a business park
that's going to generate thousands of
jobs for our local community and on the
back of that with the funds that we have
available we're going to be investing in
skills to to be able to support the
businesses that are going to come to
Gateway 14. and I think it's all part of
a grand strategy to basically bring
mid-suffolk up to a much higher level
and I think we should all welcome that
and I do appreciate the
um the amendment in terms of looking to
help some of our communities that are
not as well as I think we would like
them to be but I think you know we
should bear in mind that we're able to
do that because of the the sound
finances that we've developed over the
period and it's on top of all the work
that has already been going on to
support our communities so I welcome
this budget and I think that it lays the
background for us having a much more
healthy productive and economically
successful District Council so I commend
the budget to everybody
thank you very much and I feel like
we're
at the end of debate now
so councilor flattman
oh you've already spoken haven't you
Council of flapments
um
I'll I'll make an exception because I
don't think there's many people
counselor geek I'll um
I will allow that because
um we've we've had quite a short debate
time councilor geek
on
on sides of this chamber talking about
um and a will to spend money to get
Services delivered and and work done
um we're we on this side uh very
strongly in favor of doing that or
spending enough money to ensure the
delivery of services to a high standard
and I have been counselor only for
coming up to four years but I keep
hearing stuff about efficiency that we
need to trim and be efficient in a lean
machine and in fact what I feel is that
we can't even get the phones answered
the the delivery of services to those
who are really competent with a computer
is is marvelous but for those it's not
going to all our people and I'm hoping
that that we we all seem very
self-congratulatory but um I I'm feeling
that the actual delivery of our services
is not as good as it could be and um and
and we want to really get something done
that um that that makes a difference to
people on the ground whether or not they
are happy online
thank you thank you very much and I'll
um I'll allow councilor flatman to come
back but that will be the end of the
debate unless somebody um
yeah okay councilor flatman
Cabinet member for communities I'm very
glad that I'm being given
um half and
community and put it out there for our
community to suspend for themselves and
the limit for each one will be 20 000
those who apply if they have you know
the proof that there is need and that's
what we're here for our communities
thank you chair
thank you very much councilor Morley
um
councilor flattman's already mentioned
the community grants funding that we've
we've just included and this is
uh in addition to the locality funding
and the reason we've done it as a
separate Grant is because this will
allow for both revenue and capital
grants to be applied for and also for
feasibility studies neither of which are
currently allowed for under locality
funding so this is actually going to
make a really big difference to our
communities and they will be able to
apply to US Direct for this and of
course the money the amount is not as
restricted as for a locality fund
um I'd just like to actually respond to
councilor geek on her concerns around
um leaving behind those who are perhaps
not so technically literate
and I'd just like to give you an example
the whole point of of us becoming more
agile and Speedy is so that those who
can serve themselves are able to do so
those who can't we can actually spend
far more of our officers time in looking
after them and just like to give you an
example actually
last week councilor Hicks contacted me
with concerns about one of his residents
the following day one of our officers
was there on the doorstep looking after
that Resident and helping to resolve the
issues that she'd had
and they were able to do that because
were digitally enabled and supporting
them from the back office and looking
after both the officer out in the field
and also the resident in her home
that our teams responded in that way the
resident has had several phone calls and
they've had people our officers went out
and bought things on their own credit
card and took
and took and we are able to do that
because we are digitally enabled and
most of our officers have the
wherewithal and the ability to think for
themselves to think on their feet and
look after our residents when they need
them
so I think this is a fantastic budget I
think this is a
is going a long way to supporting all of
our residents and I will certainly be
supporting it
I will actually let counselor geek come
back on that because I need to keep
things fair and um I've given someone to
um
so um you'll have to so um if if you
could be brief though councilor geek and
then it's councilor Carter I'll be
that's a marvelous story but it should
not take the intervention of a counselor
to do that whenever we intervene things
happen fast people on their own have to
end up going to a counselor and that's
not right
thank you councilor Carter
thank you and how do I follow after that
is
a team
um it's been wonderful that she's
sitting here when we're all actually
seen to be following off the same him
she we're saying about to be uh
robustness will be commonly we need and
be
um for Budget we needing the
improvements two million pounds is
wonderful
um
and it would be wonderful as well if I
could keep a foot in my head and it
should come out my mouth as well
um
we do need a strong economy and we need
some funds going in there but we also do
need to be doing more
more so this amendment this budget where
we are helping people where we are
trying our best to actually to get
people in a situation where they can
have a safe and secure home whether
their energy bills go down it has a
benefit of Mental Health where you
actually you know you can sleep at night
where you can actually feel in a secure
place and there be able to get it out
into the outside world
and if we are able to help more people
if we are able to Aid in child care
we're actually allowing for somebody to
actually have somewhere in place
and safe and support to where they then
can go out and get what we join the
workforce where they then can actually
get outside outside their own doors and
acts to be commonly by earning and
giving back we're doing every little
thing we can do which can help either
will be of the hardest hit
if we can help them to help themselves
and then they can get out and they can
help others but now I'm always going to
be in favor of that so two million
pounds it's
it's okay it's not peanuts but it's
still a very small amount of what we
have
and too many pounds is a starting block
and I hope we can build on it every time
we do so so I'm certainly in favor of
this and I'm in favor of any time we can
go further as well
thank you
thank you very much so I'd I'd like to
take this to the um vote now please
um
councilor waiting would you like to um
add anything
described it as our budget and then I
thank the finance team but I think I'd
also like to acknowledge the um you know
what's a great set of directors and
corporate managers we have that work
very hard to pull this budget together I
mean many of us here don't know if we're
going to be here post early may but I
think what we do know is that we've got
a great senior leadership team a great
set of officers and staff who I know
will be enthusiastic and diligent in
delivering this budget going forward on
the Franklin Forest thank you
thank you I will now ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the recorded Vape
that vote is now showing in blue for
councilors to cast the vote it is shown
with the amendment
so I will say at this point in
accordance with Council procedure
um the council procedure rules these
this will be a recorded vote and it will
go into the minutes as well as on the
website and um that will be um on the in
the minutes and the website shortly
thank you
councilor Phillips can I take your vote
please thank you
chair that is unanimous 32 votes for
[Applause]
so that's carried thank you the next
item on the agenda is item 10
mc2236 the housing revenue account
um 2023 to 24 budget
so I would like to invite councilor
Whitehead to introduce this item to move
the amen and move the recommendations in
the report thank you
foreign
fenced housing revenue account before MC
so this time last year I reported how
the previous two years during covid
pandemic had negatively impacted our
housing revenue account
lockdown measures of social distancing
and seriously affected our maintenance
repair program and seriously delayed our
new bill program and since then
increased inflationary pressures
accustomed living crisis material supply
issues have created further significant
headwinds
in December 22 I gave an update on the
current year cabinet which forecasts an
adverse variance in the HRA of 772 000
we'll have a further update coming to
Cabinet on 6th of March
these are indeed challenging times but
let me be clear we remain steadfast in
our vision to provide affordable and
high quality homes that enable our
tenants to build settled safe and
healthy lives
as I explained and introduced in the
general fund budget we should normally
look just beyond just one year when
evaluating the sustainability of our
budgets and normally our stress when
introducing the HRA a similar theme that
the HRA budget should be evaluated
within the context of 30-year HRI
business plan
but this year is an exception
regrettably in my view but necessary the
HRA budget that has been presented today
is a one-year interim budget which shows
that the linear adapter to 816 000
with our HRA reserves forecast to be
around 6.3 million at the start of the
new year we can handle such annual
deficits in the short term
but definitely remaining at that level
would wipe out our reserves in under six
in under eight years
so clearly this present situation is not
sustainable over any extended time
period
therefore before this calendar year 23
is out members will be presented with a
revised and updated 30 hro business plan
setting out a clear path to a position
of long-term sustainability that will
deliver our councils homes and housing
strategy and deliver our council's
vision for our attendance
a fully renewed plan will be delivered
by our renewed reinvigorated and
refreshed housing team led by our new
housing director Deborah Fenton
in this budget we're facing various cost
pressures totaling 4.058 million
compared to last year's budget
and these are set out under 12 separate
headings in table one
but against those cost pressures we have
savings and additional income but total
3.147 million to leave a net deficit
between those two of nine hundred and
eleven thousand
members will see that we have some
significant Revenue increases proposed
for the year they're clearly set out
within the recommendations of section
three
the government has shied away from its
policy the last three years which
allowed rent increases of CPI plus one
percent
perhaps not surprisingly with CPI
reaching double digits recently the
government's decided to mandate a rent
cap
of seven percent for 23.24
within the report with model scenarios
based on Lower increase of three and
five percent in table four
but the head to our HRA from those lower
rent increases would be significant
as lower rent increases dramatically add
to the significant challenges we already
face in getting our HRA budget back to a
long-term sustainability
so the decision to recommend a seven
percent rent increase is one that I
believe will be in line with the general
approach adopted for Council house rents
across the country
the rent increases below the current
level of inflation and more importantly
given that about two-thirds of our
tenants are on housing benefits it is
below the 10.1 percent level of benefit
up list and coming their way this April
I therefore believe that we can all
with a clear conscience approve the
various increases set out in section
three
and I would therefore like to propose
formally the recommendations and invite
the cabinet member for housing to Second
them thank you
thank you councilor haddenham
thank you I'm happy
I'm happy um approving an increase in
anything is a challenging decision
and our rents as if
it's difficult it is only a decision
that is made with robust consideration
and debate especially at a time of the
of the cost of living crisis for five
years the government implemented
implemented a CPI one percent reduction
in rents and two years after this we
feel the impact on our housing revenue
account
we have an aging housing stock which
adds significant strain to the repairs
and maintenance Bill
retrofitting our homes to help with the
environment and reduce our tenants
utility bills is vital without the rent
increases will be at risk with the
increase in materials which in some
cases is 35 percent we have a challenge
in meeting the most basic repairs and
maintenance this is even before
considering the green agenda and
bringing our homes up to an EPC grade C
and above
members will also be hearing in the
coming months about our proposal to
develop creating great spaces scheme
this will be a significant investment
each year in our communities which will
be led by the tech led by the tenants
again without the rent increase this
will be at risk
um through our transformation program
our Capital program which plans to
replace kitchens bathrooms heating
systems windows and doors is and it's on
course to start in April without the
rent increase this program will also be
at risk
additional staff have been proposed in
this budget this year and these sit in
the income team officers will have
smaller patches with resulting in being
able to spend more time
in arrears or at risk of arrears again
this will be a risk if the rent
increases do not go ahead 68 of our
tenants are on benefits so they do get
support with the rent
members I know that approving these
proposed rent increases will be
difficult for you and it's certainly
difficult for me but if we do not the
consequences for our residents are
extensive we must provide homes where
people can flourish and ensure their
homes are dry safe and warm with support
when needed thank you
[Music]
thank you very much now I'll move to
questions who would like to um start
that
so if there's no counselor Mansell
uh thank you chair
um I'm surprised I want any more
questions I was not trying to be first
um I'd just like to question a couple of
points in the report relating to right
to buy I noticed that in
um section 4.9
um you've ignored any any tenants
purchasing their property under the
right to buy scheme when it comes to
your rental income
and further down in the paper
um when you talk about the capital
budget
um you refer to
building new homes and there are some
numbers there I'd like to know if those
are net gain or whether that's just the
gross of four new homes we're going to
be developing uh whether it takes into
account the fact we might lose some
through right to buy given that the
following paragraph 4.41 is it 4.4 no
not 4.41 somewhere else it says a 4.42
says that the the numbers of right to
buy sales
um seem to be higher than were
anticipated in the previous budget so
clearly they might be significant so um
just a little bit of clarity on where
it's ignored in some bits and not
ignored in other bits
councilor Whitehead
my own concerns that we put a zero
figure in there but basically it's a
question of it's how long is a piece of
string really bearing around we've got
over 3 000 houses and it's usually
around the sort of 20 Mark is not a
significant figure it obviously is a
little bit of loss of income and if it
happens half through the year it's half
years it cannot a healthier's income
um so um it's it's it's difficult but
difficult to answer if not zero what
whatever
um in terms of the capital side on the
assumption that we're seeing no loss
there then all the capital should be
additional housing but in reality some
must be replaced because I'm the chance
of it being right to buy is zero is
probably zero
question
thank you councilor field
thank you
always create anguish putting someone
else's rents up I must admit but
I think what I'd really like to know is
were there any alternatives if you
consider is there really no other way of
financing our short-term problems rather
than sticking rents up and other charges
up for some of the poorest people in the
District by sort of seven percent Which
is less than inflation thanks to the
government but um he's still
considerably more than people in that
position are likely to receive as an
income increase
um
I think that's
my concern in a way is that we're we're
pushing out rents to improve or maintain
the standards of an asset which belongs
to us the council it's
its discounted values is somewhere in
the 250 million pound bracket and and
obviously the market values perhaps
three times that so it is a very
substantial asset which belongs to this
Council not the people whose rents we're
increasing so so I personally I feel
anguished but concerned and I would like
to know what alternative you looked at
thank you
councilor White's head
first started looking at this
you know initial stage of the budget I
think it was sort of around about
September and it's quite a bit turmoil
nationally but at that point we thought
the rent would go by CPI plus one
percent there was debate nationally
about where the benefits would be not
inflated as usual so I think at that
stage we were looking perhaps lower
benefit increases CPI plus one percent
rent and anguish
and then as we got through into December
and Beyond the consultation we then seem
to flip that on its side to be seven
percent rent cap and benefits increased
in line with inflation so certainly from
my point of view our absolutely moved
from anguish to relatively calm about it
but uh you know each to the each
individual has to sort of make that own
assessment I guess
thank you very much
um I can't see any further questions
counselor Carter
I had wondered if the increase does
get to a point where somebody isn't able
to financially manage any further
what loss I would like to do should it
be intervention then to actually prevent
it going further obviously we'd have to
subsidize it there's going to be officer
time there's going to be time and cost
into doing this to be office costs so
are we going to be making any benefit
from that if we're putting in one
position where we aren't able to do it
aren't able to okay
and also if it's going to have
additional stresses on individuals
especially with the targeting we are
targeting viewers who are at least able
to support themselves
um what we are putting our problems in
if it's going to have additional
um implications to various going to be
in equations to mental health there's
going to be implications to
um to individuals be well
they were like he's been
further Innovations outside of a council
possibly Health interventions there
might be interventions from and social
we might actually drive below it would
further so are we not then spreading out
regaining our cost but spreading the
cost over a wider Community which in the
end would actually further costs to
ourselves later
so are we really doing the correct thing
targeting those individuals
regardless of benefits rising and
falling it's not exactly is it rising to
be in lathe a complete
even platform of everybody else but
still it benefits are still going to be
they're off and special social housing
and the
actually gains from them we're still
taking so how are we going to recap this
if it's going to cost into intervention
is going to be
an issue and how are we going to recap
it
well outside the division thank you
councilor Whitehead thank you um
to make some well-made points and I
certainly understand the the you know
the questions and the concerns is
Raising I mean in terms of how we're
going to handle it the process
um I'd like to perhaps invite
Deborah Fenton as our housing director
perhaps just make a few comments if you
would thank you director of housing
so we have purchased
software
um called rent sense which enables us to
use an analytical tool to
um predict not only people who are going
to go into rent areas but but it helps
us
distinguish those people who are you
know really struggling so so what what
that
effectively means is that the case loads
for officers will then reduce and
they've got more time to spend with
those individual tenants who need
support and help to maximize their
income
we'll also be working with colleagues in
communities and also our other housing
teams and we we need to have a better
presence out there in all our
communities so so our officers need to
be out there so that will that will help
in terms of ASB and neighborhood issues
and of course we have got officers in
our Housing Solutions team which are a
tenure blind so they can help both
tenants and
um people who are not tenants and
support them in making sure their
benefits are maximized and finally we
are aware that benefits are increasing
um the percentage is higher than the
rent so
um at least that gives them a little bit
um a little bit more income to play with
although that said of course heating
bills
Etc areol
um increasing
um
so so you know we will be providing that
support
thank you very much so it's councilman
Matheson followed by councilor scarf
thank you
um yeah I have asked this before this
debate a year ago no doubt amongst other
places in briefings and so on
the the
amount of money we charge from the um
public realm team across into the HRA it
seems to me that quite a lot of that
provides a benefit to the public at
large in looking after the green spaces
between the houses and because
um
they benefit other other people beyond
our housing Estates and of course those
Estates have got a significant amount of
right to buy privately owned properties
amongst them as well so the question
really to officers is have we tried even
harder than before to identify
costs which we can bear in the general
fund and not charge across to the HRA
director housing
thank you and thank you very much for
the question so this question has been
raised um recently and um subsequently I
have done some research looking at the
Housing Act and
um we can in fact
um transfer money from the general fund
to the HRA for the use of
um you know the the HRA land
um I I need to do an exercise on that
with um the director of operations just
to understand
um what that looks like and then of
course we'll we'll need to consult with
our colleagues in finance
um and and bring that forward as a
proposal
foreign
thank you councilor scarf
thank you
um
page 99 refers to the right to buy sales
and how we can retain 40 contribution
towards the cost of a replacement home
one of the key points at the bottom of
the paragraph is if the receipts that we
receive from the right to buy are not
spent within the five-year period
allowed and that's just been increased
from three to five years by the
government which I think is good they
must be repaid to the government with
four percent above the base rate
interest added can I seek assurance that
this account
me back with four percent interest above
the base rate to to central government
because I think that would be an
absolute disaster to my knowledge I
don't think we ever have but can I just
seek reassurance that we haven't
would you like the director housing to
um councilor Whitehead I mean I think um
incentivized to ensure that that doesn't
happen and certainly going forward I
wouldn't anticipate it happening but if
the director of housing wants to add
anything further
happy birthday
so we do have a development program so
it's always our ambition not to hand any
money back to central government even
more so because we have to pay interest
on it
however we do have
um we do have something else we could do
if if all else failed and we weren't
able to fund a development program and
of course that development program is
only funded through borrowing which you
know which is um
is enabled by us bringing the rent in so
very pertinent
um conversation this evening
um what we can do with those receipts is
we can gift them to
um local housing associations which will
provide housing for local people and
through doing that we can secure the
um nomination rights however that is a
final Resort a lot well the last well in
fact giving the money back is the last
resort but so if we can't build
ourselves we would always
um look for a partner
you very much and I don't think there's
any further questions so I'd like to
move to debate the normal rules apply
three minutes and speaking once would
anyone like to um start that off
so in the absence of oh councilor Mellon
yeah thank you
to say something here
um it does feel a bit uncomfortable to
be
to be voting for a seven percent rise in
in council tax rents uh when when we
haven't raised Council taxes itself and
um but I do understand the separateness
of those two parts of the council's
finances and the rules around the HRA
which prevent us from uh you know
perhaps doing what we would like to do
um
except this is a one-year interim budget
and that we're going to review the
30-year business plan which seems like a
great idea now that we've got a new
director in place I do hope that the
government will review the rules around
the hro over the longer term so we can
be more creative about how we fund this
important area of our our work but um on
the basis of um of what I've heard I'm
happy to vote for this thank you
thank you very much and um we'll take
that to the
we'll take that to the um the vote
please
um
I will now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote and I'll say again
that this will be recorded in the um
minutes and on the website
thank you chair that is showing in blue
for cancer
cancer Phillips can I take your vote
thank you
[Music]
chair that is 25 votes four and seven
against
thank you very much so that is carried
and um we've been in the meeting for an
hour and a half now
would anyone like to take a short
Comfort break
yes so your hands have gone up
um is five minutes enough does anybody
need longer than five minutes
yeah everyone's happy okay
[Music]
foreign
thank you and welcome back
um those that are watching I'm live
um
the next item on the agenda is 11
mc2237 case for a new joint Depot
so I would I'd like to um keep as much
of this debate as possible in the open
session for transparency
um the um
if um
counselors wish to discuss the breakdown
of the 12 million
um I personally don't think that's
necessary because this is just a
recommendation to look into it and start
dealing with it but um we will have to
go into closed session if that's the
case but I'd invite counselors to um put
their hand up and say they want to do
something within Clay's session but um
so um councilor Gould would you like to
introduce this item and to move the
recommendations on the report please
thank you very much Mr chairman thank
you also for your uh opening uh comments
on on what this paper is about uh and uh
let's keep it if we can in in part one
of the agenda uh I wanted to start by
setting out the companion reasons uh to
make this move uh and then focus on the
the single decision that we need to take
this evening
now we have across
the the two districts uh two waste uh
and public realm tapos one it's still
Market one Sudbury uh with a building
service is mainly operating out of
smaller Depot at Great Wenham there are
the reasons for making uh these check
this change are these both of those
Depots main Depots are 50 years old and
no longer fit uh for purpose
maintaining them is becoming
increasingly expensive
the sites themselves are becoming
obsolete due to their layout and the
number of operations now being conducted
there
uh the expanding population within our
district
has seen an enormous growth a number of
properties population uh in the next in
the last few years with uh that
projected to increase uh yet further
so the demand for service to be supplied
by those from those Depots is
tremendously increased
at the resource and waste strategy
represents a particular challenge for us
this includes the introduction of
separate household waste collections the
collection of glass from the curbside
segregated fibers and containers and
there could be a need for similar
changes to our business waste
collections also
these changes will put further pressures
on the existing Depot estate and would
constrain the services that can be
delivered on them
uh operational service savings and
income generation could be delivered in
the order of 75 to 150 000 pounds per
annum from having a single shared at
Depot
a new Depot uh would improve staff
well-being for providing a modern fit
for purpose accommodation that meets
operational needs and AIDS working
effectively and efficiently and you'll
have note in the report that there has
been a a staff working group involved in
the development of the initial proposal
and that will follow through as the
process continues and that staff group
has been in support of the this initial
business case
now having
um
in order to move forward we need
significant capital investment of the
order of 12 million across the two the
two districts
now this at this stage what we're asking
and the recommendation is a simple one
is to ask that we make that provision
within the council's budget so
mid-suffolk this is a provision of six
million pounds
uh this isn't a commitment to spend that
amount but if we don't know those funds
if we don't make that provision within
the budget we won't be able to deliver
what we must inevitably deliver in terms
of improved Echo now we don't what isn't
presented in this report is the the
solution
um at this stage all we're asking for is
that that Capital provision be made
so that the council's uh is able to
start to build up a business case and
consider the options so as picking up on
the chairman technical remarks is
tempting as it might be and I'm sure
we're all experts when it comes to
Depots as tempting is that might be
actually let us just focus on that
single uh
proposal which is to make the capital
provision this stage thank you very much
Mr chairman
thank you very much could I have a
second though
councilor Fleming I'm happy to Second
the
personal
and I'll just say a few words at this
the councilor gold has very well voiced
the arguments for having a single Depot
between the two councils and I think
that really involves putting oneself in
the shoes of the people who operate the
Depots that we've got I think if you ask
any of them they would be delighted but
the prospect of a single new efficient
Depot we already share a lot of the
equipment a lot of the fuel and a lot of
the staff
it makes so much sense and as councilor
gold has said with laws coming up that's
the waste
resource strategy that the government is
bringing in in the next few years this
will mean enormous investment in
wherever the waste is brought we will
have food waste
you know maybe glass goodness knows what
it'll all be done differently as we
believe and new facilities will be
needed in any case
the location obviously is in the future
but clearly we have the support of baber
District Council and this will be a
Cooperative effort as it should be
um the council has already also voiced
support for a shared site and therefore
I welcome this investment and believe it
is without doubt
the best option that can
thank you very much and we'll now move
to questions are there any questions
councilman Mansell
um I've got
questions
um
first one is the fact that this report
is titled the case for a new joint Depot
And yet when I scroll down to the
recommendations it says that we're
recommending oh we're going to be voting
later on tonight that we put aside six
million
to deliver improved Depot facilities
that's number 4.1 and 4.2 says that any
Capital receipts from the disposal of
the existing Depot sites will be added
to the capital repayments
now
4.1 doesn't actually say
that we're having a new Depot so surely
number 4.2 should actually say that if
we do dispose of any sites the capital
receipts should go into the budget
because we don't know what's going to
happen yet as has been explained by
um councilor Gould
we don't really know we're just putting
aside the money at the moment we're not
sure exactly what we're going to get so
I just um maybe I'm being a little bit
pedantic but we're not voting to
actually have one Depot we're voting to
deliver and improved Depot facility so
therefore we may not be selling anything
and my other query
uh is actually on the restricted papers
but doesn't refer to any Finance so am I
allowed to ask about it yeah that's
that's fine there's something about the
um building
um design proposal doesn't include any
cycle parking facilities so I would hope
that should we have a improved Depot
facility that we do accommodate
pedestrians and cyclists as well as car
users thank you
thank you I think there's a couple of
points there but um would you like to
speak to that councilor Gould or would
you like to just take that on board
uh I'm sure the latter point will be
taken on board that that the the reason
uh and uh I wouldn't accuse you of being
pedantic at all uh councilman what we're
not doing here is uh prescribing what
the outcome will be we have a good sense
of where this is going to end up and
where it seems are very sensible uh
point to aim for but actually it is and
there is an open question there about
what conclusions the further work
provided we make the provision to enable
us to do that uh where that the
conclusions that will draw and it will
be about opportunity it'll be about how
the business case develops so the yeah I
understand what you're making but uh
okay there is some deliberation in a bit
deliberate uh aspect to that and that
we're not prescribing exactly where
we're going to end up but we have a good
sense of it
counts the good we can um we can deal
with a bit of that by just adding a
little bit to the recommendation in them
recommendation two
if that became any Capital receipts from
the disposal of existing Depot sites
will be added would that Saturday with
that um yes councilor Fleming is the
seconder
that's fine okay so we'll amend that and
carry on with questions counselor
emiration
on the same sentence the addition of
instead of will
should be wood
I'm not sure I can give the same opinion
on pedantry at this point
thank you thank you and the councilor
failed
um
wondered just since it's easy to get
confused among the numbers could you be
making quite clear what the ongoing cost
or saving to this Council will be should
we move along this route
that's one issue
the second issue is when reading the
restricted papers one did come to
some concern at some of the numbers
let's
the the land valuations mentioned seemed
odd so I appreciate we can't perhaps
discuss the actual values but is there
any assurance that should be put away
this
lump sum at the moment the provision
that should you discover somewhat more
sensible and lower cost measures of
achieving these ends that will not build
ourselves a palace to use the available
money
yeah thank you very much well I find it
start to address the first point and
then ask the officers to to to deal with
anything left over from that and the and
the second point I mean my introduction
I I ever saw bandwidth of a potential
operational Savings of 75 to 100
150 a thousand but um I don't know if
they director facets Investments uh
wants to add to that and indeed answer
your second question
yes certainly thank you for the question
um so the the net impact
um that we've looked at
um which looks at the financing costs
for borrowing and then the potential
savings from the operations moving to a
single uh Depot and so the net impact
best case scenario 13 000 pounds per
annum averagely worst case scenario
around about 163
and that's primarily the the cost of
borrowing
yes
thank you councilman Matheson
thank you chair
um yeah without straying too far into
the um into the the appendix
um
how um
how was it decided that that a number of
different Services were included in the
um in arguing the case for a new Depot
without saying which they are which
might take us a little further in the
direction that you don't want to go
um so how did you know how did we come
to put all those in there
um as they are very different to one
another
direct assets and Investments
thank you and
placement in terms of moving the
existing services from the the current
premises into new facilities so that's
really where those groups were were
drawn from
thank you
um Council Phil do you want to come back
I'm sorry I missed your hand don't think
I got a second an answer to the second
part of the question
okay that's been a bit pan down here
would you like to re-ask briefly re-ask
that second question please yes it was
the issue of trying to ask it as well in
other words it doesn't get us into
our chat there are various estimates in
your papers which include
obviously there are many elements to
erecting or a Depot and providing a
large area for vehicles
the land values you're assuming seem to
me to be a number of times the values
for which we bought Gateway 14.
so I just wondered how we justify that
and my question was actually can we
ensure that should those things prove to
be just a an estimate that we don't
actually
director assets and Investments thanks
[Music]
thank you it's obviously we're having to
um make some assumptions and some
estimates
um in relation to values at a future
point in time including looking at build
costs now we all know bill costs have
been um
difficult to predict over recent times
and and so you know we're making a best
guess in effect using our professional
experience in terms of what um what
we're likely to need from a value
perspective and we've looked at other
sort of similar facilities and looked at
their total cost so I think we've looked
at it in terms of a breakdown which we
provided in terms of the the guide
within the the business case but also
tried to sort of Sanity check it in
terms of that overall number so we think
that 12 million is probably about about
right we may have estimated a little
more on land value or not quite enough
on professional fees or
you know however that comes out in the
wash and you'll point around Gateway 14
and the price we paid for that obviously
that was a much larger site without any
services and so the costs of adding
those Services uh need to be considered
so the values that we've included within
the report are more akin to a fully
service site rather than in the case of
Gateway 14 when we bought that
unserviced land effectively so it's
looking at those at those differences
but I think the importance really is
that total number so the the 12 million
pounds and their sort of sensitivity
testing we put within the um the papers
to sort of look at what
what the the broad budget needs to be
obviously as we move forward we'll get
into looking at the detailed options
that are available to us
um and that might mean that we need to
consider larger sites in order to secure
a site in the right location and and
we'll get into that detail in in due
course but at this point in time and we
believe that's a reasonable estimate in
terms of the the capital budget that we
need to deliver this project
thank you and um we are in danger of um
looking too much into this this should
be a question of is it enough money
um not are the estimates exactly where
we want them to be because the purpose
of this is to just to start looking into
that properly with actual areas of land
so um I'll move on to um councilor
Mellon
um a couple of quick questions then does
the decision today on the funding commit
us
irrevocably irrevocably if I can say it
to a single Depot or is there the
ambiguity that you've you've outlined
does that cover the possibility of a
different
and secondly in making the case for a
single Depot have we taken into
consideration the the travel time for
people working there to get to work in a
single site route compared to multiple
sites uh are we in danger of sort of
externalizing some of our costs onto the
staff traveling in
Council Gould
thank you thank you for the question uh
questions Catherine uh first
um no we're not bound to that to that
particular art you know solution though
it is what we believe and expect to be
the case but uh that might be an
alternative and uh once we've agreed to
commit this money and we're able to
start the development and the next stage
of the business case uh those options uh
can be can be assessed so we may well
not only come to the conclusion of the
single Depot's right answer but we know
why it's the right answer compared to
the uh compared to the others issues
um uh of travel time
uh both for the employees and in
question about the conduct of the
operations is a wonderfully complex set
of questions that uh thankfully we don't
have to address this evening and that as
the business case develops and those
options are explored then I'm sure you
know it'll all become very clear what
the best answer is thank you
thank you very much
um councilor War boys
thank you chair yes just do some
question
um would this be a suitable Point as to
actually sort of
consider the provision of household
recycling Depots as well
I in my opinion I'm loving wood in Stone
Market we're mid-sufficient District
Council is the largest one in the
country I think in terms of area and
having one position at one end of it
whereas one year I might be very very
useful for residents
councilor Gould
he's trying to make it very tricky isn't
he
this is of course a matter for the
county cats
and but and this matter is complicated
enough as it stands so nice try but I
think let's focus on the matter before
us which is to I hope agree to make this
provision so that we can develop the
business case for the depot
thank you councilor Stringer yeah thank
you uh I don't want to Echo something
but I I would just make the plea that if
a very early stage with this that don't
just rule out things that that might
actually be absolutely brilliant I've
long thought that a household waste
recycling center
at the very place where our brilliant
Waste Service operates out of would be a
huge opportunity to get brilliant
messages out there about
reuse and recycling etc etc so and also
if nothing but for the sake of the legs
and the spines of the people of
mid-suffolk to get a site that's on a
slope so you don't have to climb a
wretched
metal staircase with stuff teetering on
your back just to put it in a bin where
most household recycling centers now are
on split level sites to help people with
that and actually make their use that
much easier so let's not rule it in but
please can we not rule it out because if
we did find that site that I think that
would be a huge benefit to at least
explore that option and not rule it out
now and also to say that the site's
going to be really quite crucial because
we're suggesting about we're doing this
for staff well-being but at the moment
of course the existing Depot in
mid-suffolk is superbly located for
transport in terms of you almost fall
off a railway platform when you're there
and it's very very well connected with
cycling as well so there's a whole
element of of it's a real difficult
thing to ask and I don't want the Heap
loads of wants on it but let's just not
rule things out because we could
actually come up with something
brilliant on all sides thank you count
the gold thanks uh well this uh this
Administration is not certainly not
adverse to Brilliance as many of our
achievements show Castle Stringer so uh
and if if
um I think good thing about the process
here is that we're not saying that's
where we're going and and all other
options and possibilities have been
ignored we're going about this in
absolutely right way it brings together
the expertise including that of the
people doing the job on the ground which
I think uh councilor Fleming referred to
in her in second animation you know
involvement of of of the staff is is
important
um part of developing a right and if
available a brilliant answer to this so
we're not adverse to that and I'm sure
any possibilities without losing focus
on what this is actually about because
it's very easy to get distracted in all
sorts of kind of attractive
possibilities and and miss the point of
it so we'll remain focused on on
delivering what we need to deliver but
at all not not at the expense of a very
good idea
thank you very much I'm councilor
Morrison did you have something a
question
to
um sort of
I certainly agree to
this kind of uh consolidation and
efficiency Drive
in these kind of matters that
the elephant in the room is always the
potential impact on sort of human and
Labor uh security uh
so
what
do we want to do we want to acknowledge
that
um
aspect of it and
what uh impact you think
a consolidation
um strategy you might have on that
councilor Gould thank you for the
question uh I'm going to make sure I'm
understanding it first which is you're
talking about impact on jobs is that
what you're asking
um well
the
the of course our job as a council is to
deliver services and we employ people in
order to deliver those Services the
pressures and constraints are on under
places an obligation on us to be
operated sufficiently as as we can
but also part of what we're doing all
the time and we've heard about Gateway
14 a little earlier is generating jobs
within the area within our district and
we're very proud about achievements in
that score in terms of the Depots
themselves well it may well be that
we're not starting with with Staffing
Targets in relation to this again that's
a function of the solution that we come
up with uh it may well be that the sites
are repurposed sold reused of occupied
by businesses which may well generate
produce a net increase in the number of
jobs within the district just by itself
so
um I understand what you're saying but
sensitive to it uh it is it is in our
minds of course it is uh and the
involvement of Staff in discussion about
the proposals is a key key part of that
thank you um I just wanted to
um to take up the point made by
councilor Stringer actually on the um
household waste recycling aspect because
clearly that isn't a district council
function it's a County Council function
but the district councils all work very
closely with the County Council and um I
think taking this forward
this needs to be discussed at the
Suffolk waste partnership level and so
that all of the partners involved in
managing waste in the county can see you
know put this two and two together
anyone who's been to the berry Ruffin
site we'll see how very well that site
Works which is both a Depot and a
household waste reciting site combined
it does however have the advantage of an
enormous space which the
council was able to acquire a few years
ago I doubt where they will be so lucky
in this instance however I would like to
see us focus on the the whole aspect of
Waste Management
collection recycling reuse repair all of
those things need to be you know within
our sites here and we need to be working
together with our partners so I welcome
your comments councilor Stringer
thank you very much and I will now move
to debate
um the um same rules that apply as
always three minutes and please speak
only once
um would anybody like to start the
debate councilman
all my all my points um in the one
intervention
um firstly like to thank the um
whoever decided to provide us with with
quite a detailed um
sort of state of thinking on the on this
topic in the appendix so that that's
very useful to to see the ex you know
how far that has evolved
um now I did just ask the question about
the um
about the four different services and
um
as far as the the waste and recycling
side is concerned
um you know the the need is undoubted
the creating you know creating is is
inadequate and um the the secreting Road
there's no no doubt in my mind at all
about that
um the government are
promising extra waste streams to be
dealt with I welcome that
um and welcome that the thinking is is
being put into that
um however am I allowed to say how many
different Services there are
being considered
sorry
if you if you need to okay so you don't
need to please we're talking about we're
talking about four different Services
um all together in in this proposition
but that they they I think they've been
prematurely rolled together
and um so I I think finally that um
that really we need a task and finish
group of members and officers from the
two councils
um to to really sit down and
um
and you know work out what additional
information and so forth is
is needed
um such as the point has been made about
the travel times and so on and there are
many many many other aspects that we'll
need some further thought but it's good
to see that we can see the thinking that
the scenario so far thank you
thank you any other people for debate
councilor melon
I will vote for this because I can
clearly now thank you to councilor Gould
that it is simply about
giving a push to to the funds and put
and put in place
um
I I do think reading through the the
papers
um
we're talking about a very big area with
the two councils you've got right from
fresenfield in the north to shotley and
Sudbury is a big area to cover with one
Depot and and I couldn't really grasp
um how necessarily uh there would be
less travel on from one site though
clearly I do accept that you know our
waste does come to one area to be dealt
with which is you know the energy from
waste plant or or the Mirth
um so clearly there's a case there I
think it could be made and explored a
bit better I do think some member
involvement in this process might be
helpful I know it's an officer group at
the moment occasionally we're able to
bring some useful information but I
think I've heard enough on the basis of
what with we've discussed already to
vote in favor of this thank you chair
thank you councilor Mansell
thank you chair I I am
in a way I'm quite pleased that the
actual recommendations that we'll be
voting on are not tying us down to
anything specific
um as councilor Matheson has said we
have actually been given quite a lot of
quite detailed information and thought
processes and what concerns me
is really that that we might be too
blinkered because we're only going to
look at that one particular sort of
suggestion that as we've got all the
detail for
and and yes historically those those
Services the way Services Building
Services repairs and car parking have
per chance all ended up on our one Depot
site
but I don't that seems that it just
happened that way and it wasn't
engineered that way and I I really think
that
whilst I can support the recommendations
as they are worded that we are to to put
six million towards improving our Depot
facilities I really think that we do
need to have a serious think about
whether
it is the best thing for Building
Services repairs and car parking to be
co-located with waste I can really see
the advantage of having a single waste
Depot ideally if it's next to somewhere
where the waste is going to end up that
would be fat fantastic
but I'm not convinced I have yet to be
convinced that having a single Depot for
our Building Services to cover as
councilor mellons said a vast area from
fresn field to Great cornard to shotley
is the best option uh we're told about
operational costs there's quite a lot of
detail even in the in the public report
uh there are some sort of ballpark
figures of what the operational costs
will will be better because we're in a
single Depot but I can't maybe I don't
reaching I do skim read I have an awful
lot of things to read but I can't see
where
the travel um
carbon footprint the travel time the
ease of access for employers and anyone
else who wants to go there is going to
be better if we have a single Depot in
the middle somewhere of our big big area
so I I will vote for it but only because
those wordings of the recommendations
are suitably vague and I do think that
some thought needs to go in to whether
that really is the best option to put
put those little Building Services bands
in the same place as the waist tankers
because I I've yet to be convinced but I
think I'm happy that we put some money
aside for some for something to happen
and presumably
um the decision of what actually happens
will come back to council
um and who knows if we're all still here
or not could you um wrap up now could
you but anyway I I will vote for it but
only because it's it's suitably vague
and we're not tying ourselves down
please
Council of War boys
it will um
the minister said much of what I was
going to say I
I agree completely with emotion I'm
quite happy to support it
it does indicate a direction of travel I
agree with what's been
told us about the fitness for purpose of
the current Depot Market I'm familiar
with that I don't know about the the um
greeting one
um
Services need deserve I think a Depot
that's fit for purpose for the
well-being of the staff that's easy to
operate efficient and the site in still
Market simply isn't big enough I think
to sort of manage the demands that are
going to be put on it
I'm not
completely convinced about the case for
a single Depot
largely because of the logistics of the
travel concern
um
we are currently we're running vehicles
on HBO it has been mentioned that we
might be using electrical vehicles or
IGM powered I there are issues there in
terms of range and charging which could
well affect where a Depot site simply
in order to be able to access the area
it's servicing so I think that
a case for a single Depot needs to be
examined really carefully and
Alternatives looked at as well in term
of the logistics
um so that's my point I will support it
I think
it does indicate
a good direction of trouble
thank you very much councilor failed
followed by councilor parcel
thank you chair
you know try and keep it short really
clearly waste at the moment is is in a
state of flux waste collection the
government is driving change and it's
changed that largely one would support
so that's evidently sensible
clearly we have to look at the
configuration of our services in light
of that and clearly Depots that are
built a long time ago probably don't
match the equipment we have now or
perhaps even the staff so one's totally
behind us all that we should look at
this carefully and that we should have
some estimate with a sensible money that
we should put on one side to do that job
so largely one will support it
I suppose the fear I have always and
it's it's been expressed in various
other ways is that when one approaches
something like this you make a quick
guess of what might be the solution
dream up a paper with quite a lot of
detail that looks look professional
and then from then on you get to the
point where you collect evidence to
support the decision you or the
conclusion you jump to in the first
place
therefore it has to be a single Depot
therefore we have to put all services
together and I think what I would be
counseling against and I think my
colleagues have expressed to an extent
is that we shouldn't do that we should
try and be open-minded we should make
sure the choices we make are good
choices as we go through that the very
fact that we said one Depot doesn't mean
we have to have that we lose twice if we
we don't there are other options and we
consider those other options make sure
we get as best as conclusion as we can
at the end of it all thank you I'll
leave it at that time
thank you councilor possible uh thank
you very much James I'll be very quick
well I've got no hesitation in
supporting this motion I think you know
the Depots we heard have passed a
sell-by date we've got a future proof it
one of them recycling things going to be
in the future the capacity expanding
population as is in the paper and I'm
sure I'm very confident actually Common
Sense will apply if you're looking at
all the issues that people have
mentioned I know the officers will do
that well done
um and then we can come to a sensible
solution so there's a lot in there and I
believe I'm right in the same when baber
and mid-suffolk came together to have a
joint round
um with um commercial contractors that
was the first example in the country
some of us might remember that it was
brand new really Innovative and I think
this approach is going to show that we
are Innovative once again as a council
leading the way so let's just back up
and get on with it thank you
thank you councilor Emma Rosen
thank you
um
I I've got some experience in this a
little bit I used to live in uh Surrey
in in rygate and just outside of Ryegate
they had they'd done this they had
Consolidated the waste Depot
Recycling and um
a lot of council owned offices where
there were lots of unrelated activities
uh housed as well and um
and
it might sound like a small point but it
was really smelly to be to have all the
offices in that in that area and
eventually
um they invested lots of money for a new
a new facility in the center of town for
for the uh for the for the staff and the
um the uh unrelated services and
separated the two sites
um and everyone uh briefed a sigh of
relief so just a kind of a cautionary
tale already
but I I will support this uh this
motion
thank you and I think that's the end of
the debate there so um I'd like to um
move on to the vote
I will now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
their electronic vote
thank you chair that is showing in blue
with the added word any Capital receipts
for you to cast your vote
councilor Phillips can I take your vote
for thank you
foreign
thank you that's a unanimous decision
for
and um so that's carried thank you very
much and we'll now move on to item 12.
mc2238 Stone Market health education and
Leisure facility known as Shelf
um the update again this is something
that I'd like to keep in a normal
meeting oh I don't want to at this stage
go into
um the pink papers in it but should
anyone think that's really necessary we
will do it and um we'll um we'll deal
with that please let me know but um I'd
like to invite councilor Richardson to
introduce this item and move the
recommendations on the report
councilor Richardson
thank you very much chair I'm delighted
to introduce this report and to propose
the recommendations contained within it
as members will be aware the snow Market
health education and Leisure facility is
an ambitious scheme in the heart of our
district that will significantly enhance
the amenities available to our residents
this includes a new sports Pavilion
well-being Hub Athletics track and a
range of sport and Leisure facilities
at the purpose of this report though is
to provide an update to members and to
ask the council to authorize the funding
of 250 000 pounds to progress this
project to its next next phase which
will be formal planning application
since this Council approved the initial
business case last summer extensive
public consultation has taken place
including in our well-attended what next
for so Market event uh in December which
has gone an overwhelmingly positive
feedback from the community
we've also reached the point of a design
freeze for the scheme and the details
for both of these elements can be found
in the appendices in public section
I should emphasize though that if
members do approve these recommendations
in this report this will absolutely not
be the last time that this project comes
with all the council if and hopefully
when applying commission is obtained
then the intention is for a full
business case to be brought back to the
council for approval which will include
full details on both the proposed
funding strategy and
for the future
now we do have officers and The
Architects for the scheme present who'll
be happy to take any questions if if
there are any but I would again like to
thank them for all of their work to date
to help progress this scheme and indeed
to the members of the working group who
have helped to guide the scheme in its
development finally then I'll just set
up and say that in approving this report
we would be passing uh important
in making this project a reality and so
I hope counselors will vote for the
recommendation this evening which I'm
happy to propose and as a community's
health and well-being I'd like to
like thank you Council flatmen
thank you very much so we'll move to
questions
um who would like to start counselor
Pratt
yeah just a really
Quick One to begin with I just wanted to
give him my non-pecuniary interest as a
teacher at the school am I allowed to
comment or speak about this and can I
vote on it later that's okay great
um yeah um I think um you know the the
Shelf program
um does is going to entail like
many many very tangible benefits to the
community and it's a really exciting
project
um on the site at the moment of the high
school uh there's substantial uh
hedgerows and um
whilst a School playing field may not
seem like a site that's bursting with
biodiversity and there are far more
invertebrates in in the soil in the
grass than there will be when we lay a
lot a large area of that to um astro
turf and asphalt
um so I'm sort of wondering really what
we're going to do to firstly and I do
appreciate that we're not in the
planning phase at the moment but what
have we got in the back of our minds to
to preserve the current
um habitats that are there on the site
and um are we going to in enforcer well
are we going to
put a biodiversity net gain of 10
um
to to try and improve biodiversity on
the site
councilor Richardson do you want to
answer that or do you want to take that
on board
uh thank you chair I will I'll just
start by acknowledging that point and
say as you've reference the detail of
that would come through the planning
process once that application is
submitted I suspect we don't have the
the technical detail that you're looking
for uh I wouldn't be able to provide it
at this meeting I'm happy to defer to
offices if they've got more uh more that
they can clarify but otherwise yes I
have to take that as uh as noted thank
you Joe
does somebody want to take that
please
yes we're working with our public realm
team to talk about all of those things
we've got an ecologists are working with
us and we'll have further information
but we are keeping all the head roads on
the School site are staying intact
particularly to respond to that bit we
will not be removing any of those
thank you very much Council Stringer
yeah quick question uh it's about
process really uh the it says the
recommendation we're going to be
submitting a full planning application
uh bearing in mind this project is on
various different sites are we just
going to put one planning permission for
all the elements or are we going to
split that up because I'm I'm aware of
the hostages the fortune that applying
for plan admission Ken calls
councilor Richardson
oh thank you chair thank you Council
Street again I'll have to defer to
officers for the for the the process of
that thank you
thank you so would somebody take that
thank you good afternoon yes uh we will
be looking to make one single
application across uh both sites either
the Chilton way site and The Wider
School site it will be one application
yes
thank you very much any further
questions
councilor Carter
uh yes I I have a few I'm afraid and I
know we haven't got it going into
planning but it's this is for
outlining the document but uh can we
confirmed at this stage whether or not
to be accessed to the drop-off location
and parking area of the high school is
it going to be it's sold for housing as
it's been told before that wouldn't be
Financial Revival unless it was done so
um
if it is done so is be the Bungalow
which is currently used by the security
is that definitely going to be leveled
or is it going to be maintained
um as nobody has spoken to the person
there yet
uh for security guard
um if it isn't financially viable
without the housing application why
aren't we investing more to create a
more robust and stable application at
this stage
um
how do you also regarding traffic
measures for parents who use back to car
park
um how are we going to propose traffic
measures for parents to access and drop
off their children when they commute
knowing as they currently do whenever
that interest is blocked they Park both
sides of the road and it causes Havoc
for buses and the refuse carts or
anything else trying to get through
um and I'll say I'm almost mindful not
to ask but regarding the mid-suffolk
Leisure Center building which quite
frankly is on its last legs it's energy
inefficient Max and insulation correct
measures or disability access it is a
question it is a question does it given
some background to the question
um
where I skipped some of this because but
um why hasn't it been considered as part
of this when it's not fit for purpose
when we could be delivering a fit for
purpose building and create an item for
correct relationship facilities for
Stone Market and mid-suffic and be
shelf project as it is which would
landlock the Leisure Center
um which would be directly linked to the
Wellness Center
um by doing this how would we in the in
the future when it would need
retrofitting we'd need refurbishment and
it would need basically rebuilding from
a ground up to be providing with access
and we're saying how would we do that
where would be already quite located
land blocks with us with a car
facilities around it
would it be possible to actually provide
it or what would happen to a building
would we end up with a outlet a wellness
hub
which we hope will be providing our
leads
um and a then dead build next to it at
whatever stage what what happens then
um so I think those are probably enough
questions to start
there's there's quite a workload of
questions there and would you um there's
more if you want yes
would you like to go through them one
one by one or do you want to counselor
Richardson yeah thank you thank you
chair I've uh made a native of those
questions uh thank you Council Natasha
I'll go through them one by one uh in
the first I think the piece Advantage
referring to is the enabling land
um that's because it's owned by a school
is subject to an agreement
disposable disposal of the land subject
to an agreement with the department for
education I will just need to double
check with officers whether that
agreement has been reached because I
think that will in some way in some
respects uh determine the answer to your
question in terms of
um
uh travels so we have
um already begun conversations uh
looking at how we're going to manage the
travel and traffic flows from both
[Music]
and there will be a detailed travel plan
coming forward as part of the full
business case to be considered later in
the year uh in terms of the Leisure
Center why didn't we include that more
roundly I think the the first thing to
mention is that there has been
significant funding from mid-cycle
District Council to State Market Leisure
Center over the last few years and
particularly for some of their new
facilities in terms of broadening the
project to in include sorry to include a
more comprehensive refurbishment I think
primarily that would be and again I have
to take the defense officers for their
professional advice but I think that
would be increasing the scale and the
scope of the project to a significant
degree that we simply wouldn't have the
confidence about delivering it in the
round as you can see in in the
restricted papers there are already
significant sums associated with this
project and I think keeping it to a
manageable amount particularly when you
look at the other projects that are
going on within the district like the
skills and Innovation Center uh trying
to do too much in one go probably would
be an area of concern for me as a
portfolio holder I think there was an
additional question about the well-being
Hub but would you mind just repeating
that for me because I didn't quite
understand
all right
it was basically regarding real
well-being Hub which was connected to
the Leisure Center and what would happen
if the Leisure Center was proved to be
um not serviceable in future would there
be a singular building entity uh what
would happen to the external facilities
if we lost the Leisure Center
thank you for that clarification uh some
of this work will still need to be done
once we have the planning application in
terms of who would occupy it and the
service level agreements with whoever
would but
the well-being Hub couldn't exist as a
standalone facility obviously one of the
great benefits of it is that it's
integrated into the The Wider scheme but
there's nothing that would prevent it
from being used as a standalone facility
I think I've done my best to answer
those questions but happy to defer to
officers if there's any more detail that
I may have missed and I've seen officers
nodding throughout that so I think they
agree with everything you've said you
haven't said anything that they disagree
with
um
so um I I think we're quite happy with
that I'll just go to councilor emiration
uh thank you chair
um I'm just interested really uh I have
questions but
one sort of meta question is where do I
go for more in more information about
the two words wellness and education
like what
um they could include a lot so is that
is there any
um document that outlines in more detail
what those
included in those kind of areas
um
councilor Richardson and I think there's
either a document or you could tell us
what you see those two wellness and
education meaning
um I was going to say thank you chair I
think that might be entering too much
into a philosophical uh debate
um there I don't think there is a single
document we have that could point to
these two elements but I'm sure there'll
be plenty of
a wider reading around the subject but I
don't have the details of the back to
hand thank you councilor Mansell
uh thank you chair I note in um in the
communication document
that I think is part
area
uh you've got some Milestones
um and you're uh hoping that there is a
planning decision sometime in the summer
it says June in here but let's not be
specific things never quite go to plan
um and you've said it's going to be one
planning application that's a single
planning decision
um and clearly you're expecting you're
hoping that the planning decision or the
planning will be granted sometime over
the summer
um what is how you know how long will it
take to develop the whole lot
um would it be phased I mean it's one
single planning application but it's
clearly
um a number of sort of units
um do you foresee it all happening
um at once will there be a phase
development will you be doing one site
before the other site
um and how long do you think it will be
to complete the whole job
councilor Richardson thank you Chad
thank you councilor Mansell all very
good questions
um the at this stage we're not in a
position to provide all of that detail
that would happen once that planning
application has been
uh we hope approved but as I said um in
my in my introduction if we approve this
today that does not mean that's then
done and dusted and you won't see it
again my expectation would be that when
this comes back to the council with a
full business case you would then have
that Clarity not just over the funding
strategy not just over the the operating
model itself but also the time scales
for what's been done and if it's going
to be phased because I agree there's all
very important questions and we've sort
of had tentative preliminary discussions
around what that might look like but
we're not in a position to lay that out
for you in a way that's
um that certainly would be definitive uh
although I could therefore be held to
account for thank you chair councilor
Pratt
thank you I'll be brief um so a resident
had emailed me a little while ago
um he works with the Rugby Club on
Chilton fields and he expressed concerns
that the council would restrict or
prevent the Rugby Club from running uh
the licensed bar and um and other clubs
that they run on the current sites um is
is there any
um current intention to to restrict
those activities or or is that just um
is that concern unwarranted thank you
Council Richardson thank you chair I can
confirm there's no intention to do that
and if the residential question would
like to get in touch with us I'm sure we
can we can
really uh yeah sorry one more uh small
small question
um
I I'm in touch with a number of um the
dog walkers in Chilton and um there's
been concerned raised about the uh any
restrictions that might be put on um
using the children fields for uh
Dom walking uh
with the with the plans so to to
find out positions on that
councilor Richardson
thank you very much chair I have to
confess that's not something that's been
raised to me before so if you don't mind
I'll I'll hand that one over to offices
just to provide some clarity on that
thank you
um
so it's not sorry it's not our intention
to put any of the groups using the site
currently into any worse positions so
we'll be working and continue to work
with all of those groups and individuals
using the site
um there's obviously a fantastic network
of new footways and parts being created
not just on this site but on the wider
developments going forward so we would
hope that any experience with Don
Hawkers should be enhanced ultimately
thank you councilor Carter
thank you and whilst it is
you know the council that whilst
providing much needed improvements and
Leisure facilities to to the area which
are very much needed and also haven't
spent some money on pet projects like
the solar panel it might not be in a
right place and a pretty front to
Village Center is it adequate to do so
it's a very whitewash across say
inadequacy in lack of provision to
access to Leisure facilities at a heart
and central
place whilst maybe only say eight
percent of population which can't you
currently can't access the Leisure
facilities there's still maintained as
about late percent but I can't access it
and it's only going to increase the
population of less able so are we saying
that by providing additional
we don't need to work more to actually
make it up to standard now to provide
access to everybody
so we are currently working to provide
the Shelf which is wonderful but
overlooking the inadequacy of the
Leisure Center which we've spent money
on on the wrong things how are we going
to work out our
councilor Richardson
thank you chair I would slightly
disagree with the assumption that we
spent money on the wrong things at the
Leisure Center I think that for those of
us who went and told the new facilities
when they were finalized I think they
were fantastic and they certainly got a
whole lot of interest as a result in
terms of the future of the Leisure
Center itself
um I'm happy for us to go away and if
there are particular areas where you'd
like to see improvements we can look at
those
um predominantly that doesn't fall under
the economic growth portfolio so I I
don't have the detail of that to hand
but I'm sure councilor platman and Di
Robinson is the director of community as
well being able to go away and look at
that
foreign
we only have
five minutes
15 minutes sorry
um left before we have to um extend the
meeting so I'd look for a proposer and a
seconder to extend this meeting
councilor Richardson as the proposer
councilor flatman is the secondary and
can I have a show of hands everyone that
agrees that we can extend the meeting
so that that's the majority
so it's carried okay so let's move to
debate who would like to start debate
councilor flatman
left to run before we start looking at a
new pool and you're talking in the range
of probably five six more million okay
so that's not actually on the table
today I just wanted to make that clear
it still has shelf life and we can't
just get rid of it now because it seems
like a good thing to do be lovely really
lovely
um but we can't do that okay
um and the
um the matter of Wellness well-being
important Leisure healthiness
there's so many teenagers today
and
the whole generation who does need
exercise and with exercise comes a
wellness a well-being and we're thinking
that the well-being Hub is going to be
well placed for those teenagers if
anybody has anything to do with
teenagers today you know they are
suffering okay lockdown was not good for
them so this is why the wellness Hub is
going to be situated at the school we're
hoping that other children's services
might be offered there from our health
thank you
any further people for debate um
councilor Mellon
yeah this
we just
approving a small amount of money at
this stage I think to move this project
forward which is a good thing I will
just raise a couple of points that um
councilor Weller would have
raised he's had to go early but he has
raised the point of uh the the
possibility that the parking on this
project will be an adequate as soon as
you get an away team from you know rugby
team turning up they could very soon you
know take all all the spaces available
for parking and related to that is is
the the necessity of making those uh
walking and cycling connections
um to the site from within Stow Market
I know some of that is not a part of
this Authority's remake it's another
Authority but there does seem to be um
some sort of uh you know a certain
amount of slowness in that regard in
terms of getting these things moving
because they could be happening now
ahead of uh ahead of our our progress
with the planning application but I
certainly will be voting for this and
I'll be glad to see this this really
good project move forward thank you
chair thank you councilor Humphries
Mr chair thank you what a fantastic
fantastic
bit of good news this is a small amount
of money to get this thing moving
forward I can't wait to see it in front
of planning we've been waiting for this
for years not just a Stow Market but as
a district for Stone Market and I'm A
Stone Market counselor puts on the map
it's fantastic
um so thank you for all the work you've
done thank you for the proposals thank
you for the design hopefully we'll all
vote for this money to push it forward
we can get this thing done as far as
parking goes parking right now is
terrible and I live close to it it's
definitely inadequate but I did notice
in the plans that there are parking
improvements so even if it's one space
more that's a good Improvement gets my
vote and I'll definitely vote for this
thank you
thank you councilor mayor
excellent
um excellent project I shall be voting
for it but I would like to wave the flag
for the rural areas of our district
um I'm a member of Wilson Willow Sports
Club excellent Club
um it's actually listed in our Sport and
Leisure strategy as
um
very important part of sport and Leisure
in the wild north west of our district
you'll be pleased to know and I'm over
the moon that walks of the Willows are
building a gym
um that gym has received 25 uh yeah 25
000 pounds from the district
the other 75 has been raised by the club
what should I say to my members in my
ward when they asked me
Stone Market Rugby Club are getting a
new Pavilion
how much are they contributing to that
nothing
stay Market is receiving a lot of
funding from this Council fantastic but
please please do not forget the rural
areas
we need to get sporting facilities out
into those areas
they are currently funding their own
facilities and I don't think they're
getting a fair rub of the green
[Applause]
thank you very much and councilor Pratt
yeah I agree that um parking facilities
in the area is currently woefully
inadequate and um we need to improve
that and we also as as Council Mellon
has said we also need to improve walking
and cycling links to the center as well
um
kind of coming as a teacher really is if
I may
um I think you know we're covering some
really really important things
um we really need to help our students
and
Stone Market to get active improve their
physical health and their mental health
and well-being in general and I think
that a lot of the
um a lot of the facilities here will
definitely help to improve that one
thing that we might also want to bring
into it is nutrition and encourage
um students and young people
um to eat healthily as part of a sort of
well-balanced kind of Lifestyle
um and I'm not sure if that's really
part of the plan but I think food and
nutrition is all really like this
absolutely Central to our physical
health and our well-being as well and
the way that we feel about ourselves and
on the side as well
um our school has a capacity of about
eight well not capacity sorry current
number of students is around 850.
that might not be 100 accurate but it's
around that with a capacity of around 1
200 we have a really roughly inadequate
um
Canteen at the moment which can probably
uh fit no more than 200 people in their
time this means that students are taking
their lunches out in plastic containers
and styrofoam containers out onto the
school Fields some of them ended up
dumped and have to be collected by our
side team so we've got a bit of a
problem with littering it would be
really really nice if some part of this
facility could include
um
like a canteen or something slightly
off-site or some extra facility to
to do that I mean I know that's more to
do with County Council than it is for us
and for the trust but it's just some
just a point I want to make really thank
you
thank you very much and I'll call an end
to debate
um and I'll ask councilor Richardson if
he'd like to add anything
thank you very much Cheryl I will just
be brief because I know we are uh moving
up to the the three-hour map uh it's
just to thank members for their
contributions uh certainly the various
points uh raised we can take on board
and as I say you will get more detail uh
when the full business case comes back
to the council later of the year as we
said this is only a small amount a
relatively small amount of money to
progress this project further and I hope
that members will will support it on
that basis and I will just provide a bit
of reassurance to to councilor mayor in
response to his comments that this is
not a project that's being exclusively
funded by the district a key component
to this is funding from other outside
bodies including the national bodies for
some of the sports clubs involved I
won't say more than that without
straying into the restricted items but
you will see a breakdown of that when we
come to the funding strategy later in
the year but I just wanted to give that
reassurance that it's not Mid-South
expending huge sums of money
without asking for contributions from
the relevant partners as well and on
that basis I'm about to wrap up chat
thank you
thank you very much councilor Richardson
and on that note we'll go to the vote
um thank you um I will now ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct an electronic vote
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for you to cast your votes
councilor Brewster are you having
problems would you like to cast your
vote
thank you
thank you that's unanimous so that's
carried
so we'll now move on to
mc2239 Joint capital investment and
treasury management strategies
2023-24 and I'd like to invite Council
Muller to introduce this item and to
move the recommendation councilor
Mueller
apologies I'll start again
thank you chair I am pleased to
introduce this report which we discussed
at our meeting on the 30th of January
comments from the meeting were taken on
board and have been incorporated into
this report
under the Sip for treasury management
code of practice and the Prudential code
both published in 2021 and the
department for leveling up housing and
communities investment guidance
published in 2018 we are required to
determine separate capital investment
and treasury management strategy
statements and Prudential indicators
annually before the start of each
Financial year
the strategies and indicators to be
approved are in the appendices to the
report the appendices a to J can be
failing your papers starting at page 177
and concluding on page two three seven
the capital strategy shows that capital
expenditure planned for 23.24 including
carry forwards is 55 million of which
43.2 million will be funded by borrowing
limits and boundaries for borrowing are
set as part of the presidential
indicators the strategy shows that
projected borrowing will not exceed
these limits
the ongoing impact on the UK from the
war in Ukraine together with higher
inflation uncertain government policy
and a deteriorating economic Outlook
will be major influences on the
council's treasury management for 23.24
time of writing this report the
Authority's treasury management advisor
are in close was forecasting that the
bank of England bank rate will rise of
four percent in the first quarter and
4.25 in the second quarter of 2023 and
to remain at this level until the first
quarter of 2024.
there has only been one significant
change to treasury limits since last
year the amount that mid-suffolk and
baber can lend to each other has been
increased to 5 million from 2 million to
enable a more efficient management of
cash flow
now I'd like to propose the
recommendations are set out in 3.1 to
3.7 of the report and would ask for a
secondary and those recommendations are
on pages 169 and 170 of your papers
thank you chair
thank you very much councilor Miller and
I'm happy to be the second year for that
being on that committee so we'll um
we'll move to questions are there any
questions
sorry we'll meet
question from
councilor Daley's thank you chair thank
you just a quick one on the subject of
esjg uh
have you made any progress in defining
our e s g score and benchmarking it
thank you
the director of corporate resources
[Music]
preoccupied with the budget staff so
apologies I haven't followed that one up
yet but I certainly will before we bring
any more treasury management reports
back to committee
thank you very much any further
questions
we'll go to debate
would anyone like to um debate
councilman Matheson
thank you yeah I've just got one problem
with all this really and and that is
that that
three and a half years after we passed
out
um climate emergency
um motion
um we still don't seem to have managed
to have got rid of our fossil fuel
Investments and
um presumably we we're still sitting on
on a loss
um a potential loss which is yet to be
crystallized through selling and and um
selling that the Investments That Inc
that include
the fossil fuels Etc and then rebuying
them without
um without the um without including
those which is basically filtering
um ESG and run social and governance
issues so um yeah that is my one problem
with all this
the the
auction can confirm whether we're still
sitting on a loss
um
which we haven't brought into the
accounts yet
um but I believe we're going to have to
bring them into the into the accounts
fairly soon so let's get on with it and
um get rid of all the
oil and gas and coal from our portfolio
thank you
so um there's a statement there was
there a question
no no no we're in debate but I didn't
know if you asked the
um
information about
because I wasn't after the last couple
of
minutes thank you director corporate
resources yeah
yeah but obviously we are about to
prepare the 2223 statement of accounts
so we will be updating those valuations
so we will be providing an update as
part of the outcome for that
um so yeah we'll be we'll be bringing
further information forward
councilor Humphreys
Mr thank you I'll be supporting this
thank you and thank you for a good
report David
um on the fossil fuel thing I've got
shares I'm not a massive investor and
I'm not sort of in the city or anything
like that but my ones in hydrogen and
solar power they've rocketed down and
actually everything is shell and BP is
rocking it up so the statement that
we're losing money I think has to be
defined properly that's just a a belief
all right it's not facts and that's why
we'll wait for the report thank you
councilor mayor
I wish to make that point as well
um I think shell and BP have doubled in
price over the last couple of years and
let's not forget that um I know BP is
investing 20 million pounds in green
energy and vilifying the fossil fuel
industry
they produced it
so
it was their fault
so we're investing
my hydrogen shares have also gone down
so we're investing to earn money for the
people in
this um
invest in those things that are going to
give us a return and I for one will
support the oil companies as long as
they keep investing in new technology
and they're the ones that are going to
drive it
so it's not as clear-cut and we've
certainly not money on lost money over
the last three years
councilor amarosand
but I think I think reducing the
argument to you know whether whether
we're losing money or making money does
reduce the discussion a little bit
better sorry it's an investment that's
what investments are
well yes okay let's keep it yeah
um
you're right yeah we we invest in our
future and uh when doing that it's not
just about what's gonna
um make more money
uh I think
it's a nuanced issue but my view is that
companies
uh represent
um
large groups of people who
aren't perhaps pointing in the same
direction that we need to invest in
um you know there's been various
attempts by BP to
Rebrand you know beyond petroleum it was
it was
um kind of it was a it was financial
reasons that made them pull back from
that
and when you say financial and when you
say profit it's about
it's about confidence it's about how
confident we are to you know that yes
shares go up because people get more
confident because other people are doing
it
so we have to you know it's sort of peer
group so
just saying there's more to it and I
hope I hope we uh
I hope we broaden our Horizons in terms
of what
investment actually means
thank you
councilor Davies
thank you chair I'd like to thank
preparing a good report and there
they'll support that
in terms of the contentious issue we're
talking about
um I think since we have as a council
decided that we should be carbon neutral
by 20
30.
and I think that's something like only
seven years away now then everything we
can do to get there and to show our
constituents that we're doing the right
things in all aspects including our
investments and things will go up as
well as down when you invest
um I think that's to be commended
just like to finish with a final
observation and that is the Stone Age
didn't end because we ran out of stones
thank you
counselor epignon
well thank you Mr chairman um
I'm slightly concerned that
um we should be vilifying companies that
make significant contributions to the
Pension funds of our residents
when they have been working very hard to
to have pensions that will see them
through their retirement in good Stead
um I would point out to councilor
Matheson that the oil companies are
actually on balance the largest
investors in green energy in the world
today
I would also like to point out to him
that the drive to use solar energy is
predominantly supplied from China who
have building one Coal Fire Station
pretty much every week or month
to fund to to fuel the industrial
expansion
so you know you've got to look at this
thing in the round okay
um
and and the same goes for electric
vehicles
90 of the world's batteries other than
Tesla come from China and how is that
fueled you've certainly isn't fueled by
solar energy
so let's just keep a bit of perspective
the work that we're doing here is well
thought out of course it can always get
better and we need to make sure that
whatever investment we do make does
actually earn US money which we're going
to put towards Frontline services so
let's not kick the horse that's feeding
us or the bathrooms feeding us sorry
counts the field
thank you yes we must keep perspective
but I don't know whether you've noticed
the sort of charges against Exxon and
the way the research people has been
hiding information they turned up in the
1970s on the impacts of their activities
that that seems to me to me significant
a sort of related point is actually that
uh when you look at
ccla is the one I look at some of these
investment companies they're ESG related
funds do do pretty well in fact I think
better than the ones that aren't so it
isn't necessarily in almost
um penalty
it's still investing in these companies
and making profit to confess I have a
few chairs in Shell I haven't got rid of
and yes they do make a profit
but I guess one could make profits in
other ways an Academy's Factory would do
very well indeed most red light
districts do pretty brilliantly but I
don't think we would invest in that sort
of thing would we well I'm sure timely
life is to invest in that sort of budget
so you know
it's complicated but we really do
desperately need to solve some of these
issues and continuing to invest in
companies that are going in the wrong
direction is not a good thing to be
doing
councilor Pratt have you spoken in the
debate
no no okay please go now I've got your
name down but I can remember if you've
spoken or not yeah well um
you know the coal companies didn't
um lead the way in oil and gas
exploration and the railroads didn't
lead the way in constructing roads
as far as I know and
um you know in terms of investing in
fossil fuel companies it is really a
choice
um it is a choice that we are making to
do so
um I think councilor field alluded to
the fact that Exxon Mobil
um very accurately predicted the impacts
of of burning fossil fuels on
global temperatures Inc with Incredible
accuracy
but on the other hand did their worst to
muddy the waters
on the effect there was having when it
comes to vilifying oil companies I'm
afraid it's really not that difficult to
do so
um
my opinion is is that we could invest in
any number of other companies that are
developing green technologies
to lead the way forward we don't
necessarily need to depend
on those
um
you know oil and gas companies to do
this job for us
very much and we
looking at this in a um from a certain
position I think it's only fair for the
people at home there's someone on that
audit committee that um the fossil fuel
side of this is a single figure
percentage of one of the three
funds that we have so um I just I just
wanted to not get too
to I don't want to give the message to
people at home that this is all within
fossil fuels it's a it's a small amount
but I take counts as stringers yeah
sorry to continue the fossil fuel
shareholder meeting uh but uh it
certainly sounded like it from this side
of it uh I don't have any shares in
fossil fuel companies
at all and I'm rather proud that I don't
uh that's my personal
decision
uh I do have a thing it is slightly
laughable to suggest that fossil fuel
Industries are going to lead the way in
getting to the cleaner fuels that we
must provide uh within the next decade
the the Opera to suggest that 22 million
pounds of investment from BP out of
157.7 billion operating
a billion from from this one year it is
frankly not good enough they should be
there should be more uh so not investing
in them would then give that clear
signal that they're not moving fast
enough because they're not we need and
we have to meet those zero emission
targets it's not a but to suggest that
uh you know that the fossil fuel
companies will bail us out all of the
history is telling us no they won't they
will move at the syllabus rate they can
move to guarantee their profits for
their shareholders which is their first
Duty in law why would they not uphold
their first Duty in law
and the first Duty in law for us asked
as a counselor should be to protect our
residents and it's quite interesting
that some councils are saying they're
getting really good Returns on their
shares from their fossil fuel companies
yes we're all getting those returns
we're breathing them thank you
right thank you very much
um on that note
I will um close the debate
um
I'm a councilman Muller would you like
to add anything at this point uh nothing
to add thank you
thank you very much so I'll ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
thank you
we're starting and in progress for you
to cast your vote
wait for you yeah
yeah
I can take a vote now if you want
right so we're just waiting for a new
chair
do you want to take me was it gone
through
I'll let them vote verbally for this one
um I went on to the order paper to
for this thank you thank you
so chair that is 24 7 against and one
abstention
that's Carrie thank you
so now we're going to counselor
appointments are there any changes to
placings
no
um and motion's on notice there are none
so um I'd just like you to um make a
note that um the next meeting is the
20th of March
um at 5 30 but we will be having a um
group photo
for this um term at 5 00 PM so if you
could get here nice and early for that
group photo and I'll um finish the
meeting at
8 44.